[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois point le procès-verballé
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
notre ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relatif à la
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 à 2030 et pourtant diverses
dispositions
intéressants la défense
je vais immédiatement donner la parole
au président Cambon
je suis saisi d'une demande de la
Commission tendant réserver l'examen de
l'article 2 qui inclut les amendements
déposés sur le rapport indexé afin qu'il
soit examiné à la fin du texte vous avez
tout dit monsieur le président
selon l'article 44 aligné à 6 de notre
règlement c'est bien cela
vous me confirmez monsieur le Président
la Commission des Affaires étrangères et
de la défense et des forces armées
souhaitent effectivement que l'article
que l'examen d'article 2 qui inclut les
amendements en rapport annexés puissent
être examinés à la fin de notre texte
la réserve de droit quand elle est
demandée par la Commission saisie au
fond sauf opposition du gouvernement je
vois que le gouvernement est déjà dans
une forme de sagesse
et je m'en réjouis la réserve est donc
ordonnée et maintenant nous allons
aborder la discussion générale et je
vais donner la parole en lui souhaitant
le bienvenu à Monsieur Sébastien Lecornu
ministre des Armées
ce ministre
vous avez la parole président du Sénat
monsieur le Président de la Commission
des Affaires étrangères et des forces
armées et rapporteurs de la loi de
programmation militaire Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs pour avis
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
salut également même la ministre j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter cet
après-midi un projet de loi de
programmation militaire pour la période
2024 2030 le 15e depuis le début de la
5ème République et depuis que ces lois
de programme en matière de défense
nationale spécificité bien française
existe ce texte de loi pour lequel nos
armées les directions et services du
ministère travaillent depuis un an a été
préparé sous l'autorité du Président de
la République chef des armées en lien
étroit est très en amont avec le
Parlement et les acteurs du monde de la
défense ils cherchent à traduire une
conviction simple la seule qui vaille
les menaces qui pèsent sur la nation
française n'ont jamais été aussi
diverses et protéiforme que depuis la
fin de la guerre froide a bien des
égards elle nous place face à un défi
aussi important que celui qu'on dû
relever le gouvernement de la fin de la
quatrième République et plus encore les
gaullistes dans les années 60 cette
programmation acte en effet du retour
d'une compétition plus dure entre les
grandes puissances sur fond de
prolifération nucléaire de la permanence
d'un risque terroriste qui n'a pas
disparu et dont malheureusement on ne
parle plus assez ce qui me donne
l'occasion de remercier le Sénat pour le
débat que nous avons eu à quelques jours
sur l'Afrique mais aussi de l'émergence
de nouveaux espaces de conflictualité
qui découlent ou qui sont le reflet de
sautechnologique rapide et brutaux comme
en témoigne un militarisation du cyber
de l'espace ou des fonds marins ces
menaces s'entendent autant dans leur
approche classique mais aussi et surtout
pour une puissance nucléaire comme la
nôtre dans une hybridité qui nous invite
à penser nécessairement différemment
c'est là où la dimension de
transformation de cet LPM ce qui ne
signifie pas rupture intervient plus que
jamais
ces menaces nouvelles ou anciennes se
cumulent désormais plus qu’elles ne se
succèdent cette programmation militaire
a été construite en les regardant et en
les analysant froidement en y intégrant
les spécificités françaises avec nos
forces mais aussi il faut le reconnaître
nos vulnérabilités elle n'a pas pour but
de tirer les conclusions comme certains
commentateurs ou pseudosperts nous y ont
souvent incité de conflits qui ne sont
pas les nôtres et qui structurellement
ne pourront jamais être les nôtres la
France a un modèle de défense singulier
qui lui est propre fruit d'une
construction historique gaullienne
reposant sur une autonomie stratégique
française qui va bien au-delà de la
seule dissuasion nucléaire et puis sa
force dans le sentiment profond que
notre pays n'aurait jamais dû perdre de
la drôle de guerre de 1940 n'aurait
jamais dû connaître les difficultés de
l'expédition de Suez n'aurait jamais à
connaître de nouveau les guerres
d'Indochine et d'Algérie c'est toi de
programmation militaire doit permettre
non seulement de poursuivre une
réparation d'un outil de défense et là
s'abîmer dans le passé par des
politiques parfois courtermiste et une
forme de déni il faut le reconnaître sur
la réalité du monde mais aussi de
transformer nos forces sur des fonctions
militaires concrètes avec des objectifs
opérationnels précis cette programmation
militaire ne propose pas une rupture
fondamentale avec notre modèle
historique au contraire elle propose à
sa manière d'y revenir dans sa force
conceptuelle initiale c'est-à-dire dans
sa capacité à s'adapter vite en prenant
en compte les défis du monde actuel et
donc les menaces sécuritaires actuelles
ainsi qu'au technologique qui emmènent
avec eux inévitablement des sauces
stratégiques ou tactiques dans le champ
dans le champ de l'hybridité à cela
s'ajoute la nécessité d'articuler ces
nouveaux domaines de lutte autour notre
dissuasion nucléaire et de nos capacités
expéditionnelles
permettez-moi de former le vœu qu'on ne
perde jamais de vue notre modèle global
de défense dans cette discussion
parlementaire par de nombreux détails
techniques sémantiques ou budgétaires
qui peuvent toujours évidemment avoir
leur intérêt mais qui ne doivent pas
nous écarter de l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
l'exigence de cohérence et l'efficacité
opérationnelle de notre modèle d'armée
qui reste et doit rester une armée
d'emploi c'est la l'enjeu c'est la
l'héritage que nous avons reçu de nos
anciens et que nous devons te protéger
et laisser aux générations futures ce
que nous avons souhaité faire primer
dans cette loi de programmation
militaire pour les années 2024 à 2030
c'est notamment un impératif de
cohérence sur lequel je suis revenu
longuement ici dans nos travaux en
commission comme un Assemblée nationale
entre les livraisons capacitaires les
stocks de munitions de pièces détachées
le renforcement des soutiens le maintien
en conditions opérationnelles et la
formation qui accompagne nos soldats sur
le terrain
certains ont parfois le goût de la masse
de cibles capacité à généreuses la
tentation d'acheter en grand nombre des
équipements sans y intégrer leur vie
opérationnelle est un piège dans lequel
beaucoup de pays voisins et là sont
tombés et encore récemment nous-mêmes
avons parfois privilégié dans le passé
pour des raisons d'affichage ou
industrielles un nombre d'hélicoptères
livré aux armées alors qu'il aurait été
préférable pour elle de fixer le nombre
d'hélicoptères en capacité réelle de
voler nous devons apprendre de nos
erreurs passées collectivement même si
je note chez les uns ou les autres
parfois une forme de facilité ou en tout
cas un refus d'obstacle intellectuel a
considérer cette question dans son
ensemble une loi de programme n'est pas
qu'un tableau capacitaire tout cela
forme un tout logique efficace qui
s'appuie d'abord d'ailleurs sur le
tableau des contrats opérationnels la
vraie transformation est à chercher dans
ces contrats ou missions détaillées dans
le rapport annexé c'est notre capacité
demain à concevoir et à dérouler des
opérations Terre Mère cyber espace
informationnel cohésion nationale de
manière combinée merci au parlementaire
qui ont pris le temps d'intégrer cette
dimension nouvelle de transformation
notamment ce président Cambon via
l'exercice particulièrement visible
d'Orion qui a bien des égards faisaient
œuvre de pédagogie en la matière c'est
cela je le crois la véritable leçon de
la guerre en Ukraine attiré pour
nous-mêmes si nous devons donner de la
visibilité notre BITD si nous devons la
protéger la promouvoir nous y
reviendrons la LPM doit demeurer le
moment où le Parlement doit se pencher
sur l'effectivité opérationnelle ce qui
a trop souvent hélas c'était négligé
dans le passé et a pu placer nos forces
en situation de vulnérabilité face aux
menaces car précisément je sais que ce
constat est partagé nous ne tenons pas
ces menaces pour et du soir ces choix
pour notre modèle de défense nationale
répondent à la volonté du Président de
la République exprimait lors de sa
première élection 2017 mais aussi aux
besoins exprimés par nos armées depuis
lors après un long travail
d'introspection demandée aux États
majeurs et à la Délégation Générale pour
l'Armement
cet exercice assez inédit n'a pas été
sans difficulté je tiens à remercier les
chefs d'état-major le Sénat le DGSE le
Scata général pour la ministration et le
DGA pour s'être livré à cet exercice
toujours délicat ils ont abouti au
projet de loi que j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter et sur lequel vous aurez à
vous prononcer en responsabilité
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
Parlement a un rôle majeur dans les
choix stratégiques qui assureront notre
défense nationale au cours des 7
prochaines années ce rôle a d'ailleurs
été largement renforcé par l'Assemblée
nationale en lien étroit et en amont
avec votre président rapporteur ainsi
que par des amendements adoptés dans
votre commission ici même de la défense
ce disposition relativement inédite il
faut le reconnaître dans notre histoire
sous la Cinquième République viendront
renforcer le contrôle du Parlement sur
l'exécution et l'actualisation de cette
programmation notamment chaque année en
amont l'examen des projets de loi de
finances qui reste on le sait les
véritables actes parlementaires pour
engager concrètement les moyens
dans le respect des grands principes de
la Cinquième République il est évident
que le moment dans lequel nous nous
trouvons doit être celui du Parlement
depuis que je suis mise des armées un an
à votre contact lors des nombreuses
auditions que j'ai pu faire ma
conviction sur l'importance du rôle des
deux chambres n'a cessé de croître c'est
pourquoi je ne reviendrai pas sur les
enrichissements de la copie que vous
avez décidé d'intégrer en commission je
pense notamment aux nouvelles
dispositions introduites pour densifier
le bilan annuel sur l'exécution de la
loi de programmation militaire que cela
soit sur l'inflation sur les stocks de
munitions sur les commandes capacitaires
sur la réalisation des objectifs de
préparation opérationnelle ou sur les
moyens pour parvenir à nos objectifs en
matière d'accroissement des réserves je
pense aussi aux nouvelles dispositions
qui permettront la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement monsieur
le Président de mieux contrôler les
politiques publiques de renseignement et
c'est tout à l'honneur du Sénat que de
montrer que la France est une grande
démocratie et j'ai essayé à ma manière
et lors d'une récente audition à la DPR
d'accorder plus de visibilité et en
confiance dans le respect du secret
défense aux politiques je cite mais
aussi au sujet je cite de renseignements
et cela va dans le bon sens par ailleurs
comme Monsieur engagé en commission
devant le président mais devant les
différents rapporteurs des différents
programmes nous ferons preuve d'une plus
grande transparence envers le Parlement
en communiquant au président de
commission en charge de la défense des
deux chambres la disponibilité technique
des matériels et cela dès le prochain
exercice budgétaire je viens de l'écrire
aux deux présidents il s'agit là d'une
avancée majeure je le crois et je me
savais attendu sur le sujet la
communication de ces chiffres permettra
de mieux suivre les efforts consentis
par la nation illustreront bien
l'équation subtile à trouver entre
cohérence et masse
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
débats que nous apprêtons à avoir dans
cette hémicycle seront sans doute moins
un moment de vérité politique au sens
noble du terme qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au fond on a assisté à un
véritable choc modèle contre modèle en
quelque sorte ou chaque sensibilité est
plus tenter décliner les choix qu'elle
propose pour nos armées en fonction de
leur analyse portée sur la situation du
monde et ce débat a eu lieu vous le
savez notamment et pour la première fois
avec des sensibilités politiques qui ne
sont pas représentées ici au Sénat il
n'est pas besoin de les citer ce débat
est sain il n'a rien eu de médiocre le
vote d'adoption par scrutin public de
l'Assemblée nationale a été clair mais
il n'occupe pas des visions du monde et
donc de notre défense qui sont
irrémédiablement je le crois divergente
et peut-être même irré-conciliable entre
elles
néanmoins ce débat avec ses 2500
amendements et ses 90 heures d'examens
ont participé à la force du modèle
français car il a permis une nouvelle
fois au plus grand nombre de se
l'approprier et il serait faute soutenir
qu'il a toujours eu dans notre histoire
un consensus sur tout cela n'a
d'ailleurs jamais été le cas depuis 1960
et je m'engage naturellement à la même
disponibilité à la même ouverture
d'esprit pour ces débats au Sénat qui
permettront d'enrichir encore le projet
de loi dans cet exercice l'examen du
texte dans cette navette au Parlement
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant
essentiellement à l'Assemblée nationale
mais pour l'instant m'a permis de tirer
quelques premiers constamment que je me
permettrai de partager ici tant il me
semble important pour notre défense
nationale mais aussi pour le débat
démocratique
certaines sensibilités politiques non
présentes ici me semble tout d'abord
avancer dans une forme de flou je ne
veux pas dire masquer mais en tout cas
ils n'ont pas jusqu'à leur formalisé
clairement leur modèle d'alliance leur
position sur la dissuasion nucléaire et
donc inhinés sur le modèle qu'il
souhaite pour nos armées les deux
semaines de débat à l'Assemblée
nationale nous ont permis parfois mais
pas toujours de mieux comprendre ce en
quoi il s'opposait au modèle français
actuel sans pour autant jamais établir
une contre-proposition crédible
militairement et encore moins
budgétairement d'autres quant à eux
demeurent fidèle à leur position
historique depuis la première loi de
programmation militaire en 1960 en
clarté en cohérence qu'il faut
reconnaître aux parties communistes
français il en demeure pas moins que le
modèle d'armée proposé nous exposerait
immédiatement à des risques imminents si
je n'ai partage pas je tiens néanmoins
publiquement à saluer les explications
en séance du député Fabien Roussel au
nom des communistes sur la dissuasion
nucléaire
d'autres encore ne voudraient regarder
ces débats que sous l'angle budgétaire
sont toujours en définir leur finalité
militaire bien qu'ils aient directement
indirectement parfois j'ai 10 réduit les
budgets de nos armées quand ils étaient
aux responsabilités je n'y reviendrai
pas mais tenons pour l'avenir cette
approche comme un avertissement nos
dépenses militaires doivent rester
soutenables pour nos finances publiques
et être connecté à nos besoins
militaires d'abord et industriels
ensuite et dans cet ordre c'est là la
condition de la performance
opérationnelle dans la durée d'autres
enfin estime que nous dépensons trop
sans pour autant expliquer comment
répondre aux menaces à moins qu'il ne
croit pas en leur réalité ce qui me
semble ma foi dangereux et naïf quoi
qu'il en soit je respecte et respecterai
toujours la position de chacun et je
m'efforcerai de défendre cette loi de
programme et les convictions qu'elle
porte
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs si
des sujets créent le débat je me réjouis
que les discussions d'assemblée
nationale et dans votre Haute Assemblée
dessine des consensus fermes d'abord sur
quelques points précis qu'il faut je le
crois mentionner c'est notamment le cas
pour renforcer le lien entre la nation
ces armées et leur histoire que nous
réaffirmerons madame la ministre dans
l'article 11 en pérennisant l'activité
de l'Ordre national de la Libération
citons aussi des efforts que nous
proposons également pour
l'accompagnement de nos soldats et de
leur famille à travers l'augmentation
des moyens dédiés au plan family 2 qui
entraîne une forme de consensus tout
comme les objectifs de politique
salariale qui renforcent la progression
par les grilles indiciaires notamment
pour les militaires Durand et les
premiers grades des sous-officiers dès
cette fin d'année 2023 enfin
l'importance de l'inscription des
conséquences liées au réchauffement
climatique dans les missions que nous
confions à nos armées et partagés par
tous la programmation militaire actora
donc notre modèle d'armée devra intégrer
dans ses missions les effets du
changement climatique tout comme
l'effort de sobriété énergétique dans
lequel nous devons collectivement nous
engager nous y reviendrons mais cet
aspect n'a rien de neutre et notamment
pour nos différents territoires
d'outre-mer donc je salue les sénateurs
ici présents
il me semble que la convergence à la
lecture des travaux menés par la
commission je remercie une nouvelle fois
le président Cambon pour leurs qualités
va bien au-delà des points que je viens
lister et nous pouvons collectivement
tracer un constat dans la majorité des
groupes politiques ici représentés
personne ne remettant cause le modèle
d'armée proposé dans cette programmation
et dans la continuité historique avec un
grand âge que nous connaissons la
discussion va maintenant devoir nous
permettre de nous accorder sur les voies
et moyens ce qui est une autre finalité
que les débats que j'ai parfois eu à
l'Assemblée nationale qui nous
permettront d'atteindre les objectifs
militaires que nous partageons donc je
le crois majoritairement je ne
reviendrai pas en détail sur l'ensemble
des sujets l'examen en séance nous
permettra d'avoir des discussions
approfondies et c'est aussi pour cela
que j'ai déposé une cinquantaine
d'amendements du gouvernement pour que
nous puissions revenir en détail et
débattre utilement sur les thématiques
qui méritent une attention particulière
je souhaite prendre maintenant quelques
instants avant de conclure pour revenir
sur les questions sur lesquelles les
débats doivent nous permettre de trouver
un compromis et un accord je vais vont
revenir sur les sujets sur lesquels la
version du texte tel qu'elle ressort de
la commission crée un potentiel
désaccord on le verra entre le Sénat le
texte issu de l'Assemblée nationale je
souhaite que nos discussions en séance
c'est jour durant permettent de
retravailler le texte pour répondre à la
volonté du Sénat tout en s'assurant de
la cohérence du texte final quelque
chose que vous souhaitez bien
naturellement commençons par évoquer
l'éléphant au milieu de la pièce le
sujet budgétaire il est naturellement
structurant l'ambition du texte présenté
par le gouvernement était proposé une
trajectoire budgétaire au service d'une
ambition militaire documentée et
crédible c'est à dire le fait de
financer des capacités d'agir concrètes
en cohérence avec les menaces et la
défense de nos intérêts évidemment à
cela s'ajoute notre pratique d'exécution
à l'euro près et à vrai dire et même de
surexécution sur la fin de période de
LPM actuelle je suis déjà longuement
revenu et qui doit nous conduire à nous
assurer la soutenabilité de la
trajectoire et de l'enveloppe globale
pour nos finances publiques dans la
durée j'entends dire que nous reportons
l'essentiel de l'effort après l'élection
présidentielle de 2027
je rappelle qu'en 2017 le budget des
armées était de 32,3 milliards d'euros
qu'en 2023 vous avez voté sur
proposition du gouvernement un budget de
43,9 milliards d'euros qu'en 2027 à la
fin du second quinquennat en l'état en
tout cas de la discussion d'Emmanuel
Macron le budget des armées sera de 56
milliards d'euros soit une marge de
mentation de 23,7 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2017 pour finalement aboutir à
68,9 milliards d'euros ce qui aura
permis de plus que doubler le budget de
nos armées en deux lois de programmation
militaires c'est cela la réalité de
l'effort consenti par la nation pour ses
armées sous l'impulsion du chef de
l'État avec l'appui du chef d'état-major
des armées nous avons pris le parti de
privilégier la cohérence sur la seule
masse c'est au fond l'exigence de
regarder dans le rapport annexé autant
le tableau des contrats opérationnels
que celui des équipements capacitaires
le dernier n’étant au service que du
premier je le rappelle une nouvelle fois
la même logique s'applique pour nos
soutiens comme par exemple le service de
santé des armées ou le commissariat il
en va de même pour notre politique
innovation qui nous permettra d'être au
rendez-vous des sous technologiques de
demain je pense notamment au spatial
aussi beh à l'intelligence artificielle
au quantique en application militaires
et bien sûr monsieur le sénateur Perrin
au drone le Sénat propose au de la même
de la seule trajectoire une enveloppe
globale financière différente nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure sur le
terrain plus technique passant l'effort
global de 413 à 420 milliards d'euros
comme je vous le disais je suis ouvert
au débat et je le redis solennellement
ici madame messieurs les sénateurs à la
tribune et je serais donc heureux que
nous puissions avoir une discussion
nourrie précise et cohérente sur ces 7
milliards d'euros supplémentaires votés
en commission mais je le redis la
soutenabilité pour nos finances
publiques à ce stade de la rédaction du
texte m'interroge mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs un autre point me tient à cœur
et personne ne le découvra ici puisque
j'y reviens à chaque fois devant vous
depuis plus d'un an c'est que la haute
programmation militaire ne doit pas être
un carcan qui contraint nos armées je
sais que vous en conviendrez pour
prendre par ailleurs plus de liberté
pour ne collectivités locales
comparaison n'est pas raison mais
certaines modifications apportées en
commission apportent je le crois une
forme de rigidité au texte là où une loi
de programmation militaire au sens
gaulliste du mot ne doit pas être une
loi de prescription technique mais au
contraire prendre de la hauteur et
assigner les objectifs stratégiques
c'est prescription peuvent créer un
cadre trop strict pour nos états majors
et surtout ne pas être adapté à la
réalité de la vie des armées or je leur
fais personnellement toute confiance et
je ne doute pas un seul instant que vous
aussi pour réaliser les objectifs qui
sont assignés je pense particulièrement
la trajectoire de monter en puissance
des réserves à la chronique annuelle
pour le MCO et pour l'innovation ce
n'est pas le rôle d'une LPM de mon point
de vue que de fixer ce niveau de détail
proposait donc par voie d'amendement du
gouvernement à ce que nous revenions à
une épure plus traditionnelle de ce qu'à
mon sens doit être une loi de
programmation mais je sais qu'un certain
nombre d'entre vous m'ont fait déjà
savoir que ces modifications sont aussi
des modifications d'appel pour permettre
au
[Musique]
environ opérationnel que le Sénat
souhaite renforcer vont dans le bon sens
même si la copie initiale de mon point
de vue était solide mais une fois de
plus grâce à vos amendements les doutes
sont donc complètement dissipés et c'est
une bonne chose que la Commission à
introduite sur le sujet du service
national universel même s'il nous faudra
renforcer la cohérence de la légistique
sur l'ensemble du texte au fur et à
mesure des différents amendements donc
du rédactionnel en quelque sorte vous
avez souhaité mettre au clair qu'il ne
figurez pas dans la loi de programmation
militaire c'est ce que je dis depuis le
début des discussions j'ai souscrit donc
complètement et là aussi ce sont des
modifications qui sont les bienvenus
souscrit également à la volonté des
sénateurs de développer des mécanismes
pour mieux financer les entreprises
monsieur le Président Cambon et un
certain nombre de vos collègues en
particulier des PME sur lequel vous êtes
revenus nombreuses fois dans notre pays
TD cette loi de programmation militaire
ne clôture pas complètement ce chantier
mais les réflexions permettront j'en
suis certain de trouver des solutions
adaptées pour ces entreprises qui font
partie de notre modèle de défense en
tout cas c'est un sujet d'actualité
qu'on ne peut pas balayer d'un revers
donc là aussi je suis à votre
disposition pour améliorer le texte vous
avez enfin tenu à développer le patch
sur la souveraineté dans nos outre-mer
vous savez que c'est un sujet qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur ainsi que
au président du Sénat par ailleurs nous
avons échangé encore récemment sur ce
point et ce sont pour la plupart des
engagements que j'avais pu prendre
oralement au gré des différents débats
et votre version enrichie rapport annexé
elle est donc la bienvenue et j'y
suiscri là aussi pleinement c'est un
signal stratégique particulièrement fort
que le Sénat envoie mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pour conclure
comme je le disais je pense sincèrement
que nous sommes d'accord sur l'essentiel
c'est à dire sur ce qui est bon pour nos
armées les débats que nous demandons pas
d'avoir ces prochains jours nous
permettront de combler les écarts entre
nos positions peut-être tout simplement
de mieux les expliciter donc mieux les
comprendre donc mieux les accepter qui
ne concerne pas tant les objectifs que
les voix et moyens pour y parvenir si
l'on considère que le principe de
réalité s'applique à chacun ce que je
crois je ne vois rien à surmontable et
je sais que la qualité du travail de
cette chambre confirmera nos convictions
communes et l'indispensable cohérence
que nous devons préserver entre les
objectifs que nous assignons à nos
armées pour la protection de la nation
et les moyens que nous leur attribuons
pour les 7 prochaines années pour nos
soldats en ayant une pensée pour les
tuer et les blessés pour notre nation
car c'est Toi de programmation militaire
doit garantir notre sécurité en assurant
pour les 7 prochaines années et pour
longtemps encore le succès des armes de
la France je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant
président Cambon rapporteur de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la défense c'est la première raison
d'être de l'État
cette affirmation du général de Gaulle
résonne gravement à la lueur des
événements survenus ces derniers jours
en Russie
en matière de géopolitique en matière
militaire des bousculements soudains
violents et imprévisibles se produisent
chaque jour sous nos yeux et pourtant
aujourd'hui il nous faut sortir de
l'actualité pour nous projeter dans le
temps long c'est le difficile exercice
tout à fait stimulant par ailleurs
auquel nous invite l'élaboration d'une
loi de programmation militaire
une LPM se sont précisément les moyens
que collectivement nous mettons à leur
disposition pour permettre à nos soldats
d'atteindre cet objectif mais ce sont
aussi des moyens pour prévenir nos
militaires du danger auquel il s'expose
pour nous en protéger
face au péril nous rendons aujourd'hui
hommage alors courage à leur
détermination et alors compétences qui
n'ont jamais fait et qui ne feront
jamais défaut à la nation à travers
cette loi de programmation militaire
c'est aussi la nation qui leur rend
hommage et qui leur affirme leur soutien
nos débats revêtent donc une importance
singulière et ce d'autant plus qu'ils
interviennent dans un contexte de grands
chamboulement
bien sûr nous ne pouvons placer nos
travaux sur ce texte fondamental sous le
seul prisme de la guerre en Ukraine car
bien d'autres paramètres actuels ou en
devenir devront être prises en
considération mais reconnaissons tout de
même que l'agression russe est un
événement majeur qui a tout changé les
équilibres diplomatiques mondiaux à la
donne stratégique sur notre continent
c'est du reste précisément pour cela que
le Président de la République a souhaité
interrompre la programmation actuelle
deux ans avant son terme pour en
proposer une nouvelle monsieur le
ministre il est important de rappeler ce
contexte car il permet de bien
comprendre la démarche de notre
commission le point de départ logique de
toute LPM c'est l'analyse des menaces
alors si nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
et pas en 2025 pour étudier ce projet de
loi c'est qu'elle a les menaces se sont
accrues
dès lors nous nous attendions à une
accélération de l'effort de remontée en
puissance des moyens de nos armées vous
le savez monsieur le ministre sera là
l'un des points principaux de débats
entre le gouvernement et le Sénat car en
l'état la trajectoire que vous nous
proposez ne marque de notre point de vue
aucune différence avec celle prévue par
la LPM précédente ce n'est pas logique
car si les menaces sont avérées alors
les besoins qui en découlent aussi le
sont tout autant
notre commission ne conteste pas
l'effort louable du gouvernement et elle
lui rend hommage le gouvernement propose
en effet une enveloppe de 413 milliards
d'euros répartis sur 7 ans au total si
cette programmation va à son terme nous
aurons bien eu plus qu'un doublement de
notre effort de défense entre 2019 et
2030 ayant été rapportés des deux LPM je
peux en témoigner ici et je souhaite que
ce soit bien noté mais notre commission
après avoir salué cet effort a aussi
identifié plusieurs sujets de
préoccupation bien sûr c'est d'abord la
question de l'inflation vous avez évalué
son impact à 30 milliards d'euros ce qui
est considérable sur l'ensemble de la
programmation peut-être même est-ce une
estimation assez optimiste
c'est aussi c'est surtout la question
des ressources extra budgétaires comme
vous le savez notre commission c'est
toujours opposé dans toutes les LPM
précédentes au recours à ce type de
financement pour boucler les besoins de
programmation
alors certes une partie de ces recettes
affectées seront très probablement au
rendez-vous leur affectation nous semble
donc assez logique et juste je pense par
exemple aux ressources générées par
l'activité du service de santé des
armées les votes les ventes des
fréquences ou les ventes immobilières en
revanche une seconde catégorie nous
paraît beaucoup plus incertaine ces
fameux 7 milliards que le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques a ici
publiquement qualifié de non documenté
tout le problème est donc là monsieur le
ministre
contrairement à ce que vous nous dites
le Sénat est une assemblée raisonnable
et très attentive à l'équilibre des
finances publiques et nous n'entendons
pas dépasser l'enveloppe des besoins de
413 milliards d'euros alors peut-être
avez-vous changé la méthodologie mais
nous restons sur notre principe
simplement dans une volonté de clarté la
Commission a voulu sécuriser les crédits
qui ont été annoncés comme objectif par
le Président de la République à
Mont-de-Marsan soit 413 milliards or ces
413 milliards sécurisés nous ne les
retrouvions pas dans votre texte
naturellement si dans le futur des
marges frictionnelles
j'explique qu'il s'agit par exemple de
retard de livraison si ces marges
frictionnelles interviennent ces crédits
ne seront pas dépensés concrètement si
vous avez commandé un Airbus A400M vous
l'avez commandé qui n'est pas livré il
ne sera pas payé et vous pourrez en
tirer les conséquences dans chaque loi
de finance à venir
dans les circonstances actuelles le but
n'est pas de préparer la guerre en
Ukraine dans laquelle nous ne sommes pas
belligérants le but c'est de nous
préparer au mieux aux menaces de demain
alors ne perdons pas de temps grâce à un
cadencement des dépenses beaucoup plus
ambitieux renforçons immédiatement
l'entraînement de nos armées les
soutiens qui sont indispensables à leur
efficacité et la condition militaire à
un moment où la question de
l'attractivité du métier des armes se
pose de façon brûlante 1500 postes
étaient tout recrutement 700 ont été
pourvus les réponses de notre modèle
d'armée sont encore marquées trop hélas
par les dividendes de la paix pas
suffisamment de masse pas assez de
stocks des réductions temporaires de
capacité des niveaux d'entraînement
insuffisants face aux objectifs nous
retrouvions dans le bleu un objectif de
147 heures d'entraînement pour des
pilotes de Rafale les normes autant sont
de 220 heures
la valeur l'engagement et le
professionnalisme de nos armées sont
largement reconnus par nos alliés et
même par nos adversaires mais ils ne
peuvent compenser les effets de 25 ans
des rendements dans le cadre des
dividendes de la paix avec les
opérations en Afghanistan en Libye en
bancsarienne nos références ont été
recentrés sur un modèle de conflit
asymétrique dans le cadre de la
projection de nos forces mais c'est bien
d'autres un autre type de conflit qui
est revenu au premier plan avec
l'invasion de l'Ukraine celui de la
haute intensité c'est pourquoi à
l'annonce du nouvel LPM notre commission
a voulu fonder ses choix sur une analyse
rétrospective de ces dernières années et
ce n'était pas regardé dans le
rétroviseur nous avons ainsi lancé sept
rapports préparatoires un retour
d'expérience de l'opération barkhane et
de la guerre contre le terrorisme un
retour d'expérience de la guerre
d'Ukraine dont je souligne à nouveau
qu'elle doit nous éclairer sans nous
aveugler et 5 rapports thématiques
correspondant à chaque problème chaque
programme budgétaire intéressant nos
armées
à l'issue de cette importance travail
préparatoire nous tirons principalement
deux conclusions que le texte adopté par
la commission traduit concrètement
premièrement nous devons mobiliser plus
rapidement les crédits prévus sur
l'ensemble de la programmation ce
cadencement révisé de nos efforts doit
nous permettre de mieux financer et ce
dès l'année prochaine tout ce qui
conditionne le niveau d'activité de nos
forces qu'il s'agisse de leur
entraînement à proprement parler de
l'entretien du matériel des stocks ou
encore des capacités du service de santé
des armées nous possédons à l'heure
actuelle quatre régiments de Charles
Clerc et si on met bout à bout leurs
heures d'utilisation on s'aperçoit
qu'ils sont à 50% seulement de leur
capacité
[Musique]
ce contexte principal de nos efforts les
moyens de contrôle du Parlement monsieur
le ministre nous le redisons ici le
Sénat n’entend pas se substituer à
l'exécutif ni empiéter sur ses
prérogatives en revanche nous en sommes
absolument convaincus nous ne pouvons
pas demander aux Français de consentir
dans la durée un tel effort budgétaire
sans leur garantir en même temps que le
Parlement exécutera pleinement sa
mission de contrôle que lui confie la
Constitution pour le dire franchement
l'actualisation ratée de 2021 a laissé
ici un souvenir assez amer
notre Commission présente donc un
certain nombre de modifications qui dans
leur esprit sont du reste en cohérence
avec plusieurs ajouts de nos collègues
de l'Assemblée nationale
monsieur le ministre il s'agit de sujets
sur lequel notre commission travaille
depuis de nombreuses années nos
propositions dans ce domaine nous
paraissent à la fois raisonnable et plus
que jamais dans les temps que nous
connaissons ces propositions sont
opportunes en conclusion et avant
d'ouvrir nos débats je souhaiterais
remercier tous nos collègues qui ont
participé à la préparation de ce texte
si important et en premier lieu les 11
commissaires de ma commission qui
montent assister dans la préparation de
mon rapport en second lieu je voudrais
saluer remercier les rapporteurs pour
avis de la commission des lois François
Noel buffet et la commission des
finances de Munich delaige qui ont
enrichi le texte de leur apport et enfin
bien sûr tous les auteurs d'amendement
de tous les groupes qui expriment
l'importance de ce texte pour notre pays
et j'ai veillé à ce que chaque groupe
puisse contribuer par l'acceptation de
leurs amendements à la réalisation de ce
texte monsieur le ministre le Sénat est
ici plein de bonnes volonté avec une
frange volonté d'aboutir nous comptons
bien évidemment sur votre écoute vous en
avez fait quelques ouvertures ici il y a
un instant vous pourrez compter sur
notre mobilisation mais surtout sur
notre ambition pour nos forces armées je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant appeler la tribune
Monsieur Dominique de Lège rapporteur
pour avis de notre commission des
finances
sur le rapporteur sur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
sur le président de la Commission de la
Défense chers collègues 5 minutes pour
400 milliards difficiles d'émettre un
avis circonstanciel aussi je me bornerai
vous proposer trois considérations la
première le contexte économique est
général monsieur le ministre vous aimez
citer le général de Gaulle dont les
décisions et actions ont été marquées
par le souci de l'indépendance et de la
souveraineté de la France l'armée sa
dissuasion et contribue au premier plan
mais là cela ne suffit pas quelle est la
souveraineté l'indépendance d'un pays
qui consacre plus d'argent à la charge
de sa dette car sa défense la dette sera
supérieure de près de 10 milliards
d'euros au budget de la défense en 2025
soit excusez-moi la comparaison mais le
coût d'un porte-avions
quelle est la souveraineté
l'indépendance d'un pays dans le déficit
du commerce extérieur et trois fois
supérieur au montant du budget des
armées déficit dont une partie est liée
à ses approvisionnements alimentaires et
énergétiques quand il ne s'agit pas des
matières premières indispensables à
notre industrie de la défense je vous
donne bien volontiers actes que l'actuel
et le PM a été respecté dans sa
trajectoire budgétaire pour autant celle
que vous nous soumettez avec la
multiplication de textes programmatique
va se trouver en concurrence avec les
lois de programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur de la recherche de la
justice et tant d'autres annonces
transitions énergétiques accès aux soins
éducation le tout avec l'objectif
maintes fois annoncé de réduire le
déficit public pour le ramener à 3% en
2027 une gageure comme la démontré le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
lorsque tout devient prioritaire il y a
urgence à faire des choix
la deuxième considération porte sur la
crédibilité financière rien ne vous
obligeait à faire une nouvelle LPM dès
cet été et donc à recourir à la
procédure accélérée puisque l'actuel loi
court jusqu'en 2025 sans contester la
nécessité de la justice pour mieux
intégrer le MCO qui conditionne la
disponibilité effective de nos armements
et la montée en puissance du suaire
j'observe que l'ambition capacitaire de
2030 est reportée à 2035 sur fond de
retour de guerre sur le sol européen
plus promématique et la trajectoire
proposée puisque le président de la
République qui ventra les mérites de ces
lois dès le 14 juillet prochain n'est
pas celui qui aura trouvé les milliards
annoncés à compter de 2028 laissé à
d'autres le soin de financer dans cinq
ans les décisions prises aujourd'hui
n'est pas acceptable politiquement ni
démocratiquement sans compter qu'une
telle trajectoire des crédits serait en
contradiction avec le concept
commis de guerre qu'introduit cette LPM
et que vous avez défini comme produit
plus produire plus vite et moins cher au
final on risque de produire moins moins
vite et plus cher la montée en puissance
doit donc débuter dès cette législature
par ailleurs on peut s'interroger sur
les fameuses marges frictionnelles qui
consiste d'anticiper des retards de
livraison ou de paiement les reports de
charge devraient approcher les 5
milliards d'euros en 2023 avec les 6,2
que vous projetez pour la période 2024
2030 ce sont près de 11 milliards qui
manquent soit 20% d'une année de
fonctionnement ou encore un porte-avion
de notre point de vue dès lors qu'un
besoin de besoin financier estimé à 413
milliards d'euros il doit être inscrit
dans la loi il doit être intégralement
couvert par des crédits budgétaires
exceptions faites de recettes extra
budgétaires
documentés c'est pourquoi nous proposons
de porter un minimal l'enveloppe des
crédits à 407,4 sur cette période à
défaut de garantie sur ces deux points
une révision de la trajectoire pour la
rendre plus linéaire sur la période et
une réévaluation du besoin de
financement plus réaliste nous
considérons que la crédibilité la
sincérité de steak ne sont pas acquises
troisième considération sur la méthode
monsieur le ministre vous êtes en
quelque sorte la victime de la manière
dont le gouvernement a traité le
Parlement tout au long de l'actuel LPM
et singulièrement de son refus
d'appliquer l'article 7 qui prévoyait
qu'il serait invité à débattre de son
actualité
nous avions cru désolé jusqu'à des
propos récents que vous étiez dans un
autre état d'esprit nous nous en
réjouissions mais chaudée nous
souhaitons avoir des garanties et c'est
le sens de nombreux amendements qui
viennent non pas modifier le rôle du
Parlement mais tout simplement veiller à
lui permettre de l'assumer en disposant
des procédures et informations
indispensables à sa mission la situation
géopolitique économique et sociale voire
intérieure requier plus que jamais
lucidité et courage tout au long de la
discussion nous serons guidés par deux
objectifs un texte de vérité plutôt
qu'un texte d'affichage un parlement qui
entend prendre toutes ses
responsabilités constitutionnelles
c'est-à-dire voter et contrôler c'est le
sens des amendements de la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
dont je salue la qualité du travail
c'est le sens des amendements et
précision que nous lui avons proposé et
qu'elle a bien voulu retenir c'est
pourquoi sous réserve de leurs adoptions
la commission des finances donne un avis
favorable je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le reporter
la parole est maintenant président
François Noël buffet rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des lois
le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur
président de la commission aux affaires
étrangères de la défense chère Christian
Cambon chers collègues la commission des
lois s'est saisi de trois sujets au sein
de ce texte les dispositions relatives
aux renseignements à la sécurité des
systèmes d'information et la protection
contre les drones malveillants tout
d'abord nous devons nous féliciter que
les trois services de renseignement
relevant du ministre des Armées desse
des RSD et DRM voient leur effectif
augmenter leur investissement immobilier
et opérationnels financés c'est là le
premier objectif de l'ordre de
programmation les dispositions inscrites
dans le texte du Gouvernement
s'inscrivent dans le prolongement des
textes antérieurs la commission des lois
les a approuvées sous réserve de
précision mais le projet de loi ne
comportait aucune disposition pour
renforcer le contrôle des dix services
de renseignement et ça alors même que
l'équilibre entre l'extension des
pouvoirs des services et les instruments
de contrôle est essentiels à la
conformité de notre régime aux exigences
constitutionnelles en matière de
protection des libertés et à la
jurisprudence européenne la Commission
comme la commission des affaires
étrangères et la défense et les
sénateurs membres de la DPR ont souhaité
que l'information de celle-ci et le
contrôle exercé par la Commission
nationale de contrôle des techniques et
de renseignement soit renforcés il
s'agit d'abord de garantir que lorsque
les sujets d'actualité concernant une
action des services de renseignement
sont révélés à la presse et ont été
admis par le gouvernement ceux-ci puisse
faire l'objet d'un suivi par la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement c'est un sujet qui a pu
donner lieu à divergence à différentes
interprétations entre la délégation et
le gouvernement et l'année dernière mais
qui depuis a fait l'arbitrage a fait
l'objet d'un arbitrage au plus haut
niveau de l'État que nous consacrons
désormais dans la loi les ajouts
apportés au stade de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense
permettent également de renforcer les
liens entre la DR et la cnctr en
prévoyant la présentation à la
délégation d'un bilan annuel des
recommandations de la commission ainsi
que son information sur les saisines du
procureur de la République dans le cadre
des dispositifs de lanceur d'alerte
enfin le dernier amendement tant à
permettre l'accès immédiat de la SNCF de
la snctr aux éléments collectés par les
services de renseignement lors de la
mise en oeuvre des techniques les plus
intrusives donc il faut souligner que
nous contestons pas nous contestons pas
la légitimité bien sûr je note
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement souhaite
la suppression de cet article 22 quater
pour des raisons de principes et de
calendrier sur les principes il est
important que le développement des
techniques les plus intrusives
s'accompagne d'une amélioration des
moyens de contrôle ce que nous ne ce que
nous souhaitons assurer par cet article
sur le calendrier monsieur le ministre
il est bien sûr nécessaire de prendre en
compte les contraintes opérationnelles
nous pourrons donc y revenir il n'est
pas question de placer en difficulté nos
services dans des ce qui ne serait pas
naturellement acceptable comme tenu des
projets et des objectifs que nous
partageons dans la même logique afin
d'éviter les mettements du contrôle nous
avons souhaité que la cnctr puisse
donner un avis avant la prise des
décrets renforçant les pouvoirs de Nancy
en effet il faut le redire à ces
tribunes l'an n'est pas un service de
renseignement elle n'est pas un service
de renseignement ces liens avec ceux-ci
sont étroits et la nature de son
intervention appelle un regard informé
par la pratique de ces services un mot
enfin d'un sujet qui va peser dans le
cadre légal du renseignement le régime
encadrant les échanges d'information
entre les services français de
renseignement les services étrangers
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible à
tel enseigne que nous n'avons pas
souhaité mais je n'ai pas voulu y
intégrer dans le texte le sujet par voie
d'amendement en revanche il faudra dans
un délai assez rapide que les choses
puissent être réglées la délégation
parlementaire enseignement reste je le
crois le lieu d'échanges le plus
efficace sur ce sujet s'agissant de la
sécurité des systèmes d'information les
articles 32 à 35 renforcent la capacité
de l'acier de détecter
identifier et prévenir les attaques
informatiques visant les systèmes
d'information des autorités publiques
des opérateurs stratégiques ou de leur
sous-traitants ces dispositions vont
dans le bon sens d'une meilleure défense
de la France et nous avons été favorable
sous réserve de quelques précisions
sachant d'un régime de lutte contre les
drones malveillants l'article 27 du
projet de loi vise à doté nos services
de l'État de moyen de Paressant délai à
des menaces imminentes il a par il a
paru à la commission nécessaire de
renforcer des garanties en ce qui
concerne notamment les droits de
propriété le droit d'informer un
amendement était déposé dans ce sens
sous réserve de ces amendements qu'elle
a soumis et qui ont été adoptés par la
commission des lois la commission des
lois considérée que le projet de loi et
bien naturellement par la commission de
la défense monsieur le Président je
m'excuse de l'avoir
omi a considérer que le projet de loi
comporte des mesures utiles pour les
services de renseignement et pour la
sécurité des systèmes d'information et
donc émis un avis favorable à l'adoption
de ce texte merci merci monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]
nous allons passer à la discussion de la
motion qui tente à opposer la question
préalable Monsieur Pierre Laurent et des
membres du groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologie sont des mesures
distribuées ce numéro 37 qui tente à
opposer la question préalable je vais
donner la parole au président Pierre
Laurent pour la motion
la parole
sur le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues avec cette question préalable
le groupe CRCE souhaite poser à notre
Haute Assemblée une question simple
est-il vraiment sérieux de débattre dans
ces conditions du loi de programmation
militaire d'un montant exceptionnel de
413 milliards d'euros son ampleur le
tournant stratégique quel opère son
poids énorme face à tous les autres
budgets de la Nation pour le climat à la
réindustrialisation le logement la santé
l'éducation tout appelait à ce qu'elle
fasse l'objet d'un large au débat avec
la nation le terme initial de l'actuel
LPM en 2025 le permettait monsieur le
ministre le 22 mai à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez vous-même déclaré
que cette LPM est je cite un défi aussi
important que celui qu'on dû relever les
gaulisses dans les années 60 c'est vrai
mais avec une différence de taille le
général de Gaulle installé alors le
choix de construire l'indépendance de
notre défense vous faites pour lui celui
de l'autanisation et de la guerre le
débat démocratique sur vos joies sur vos
choix n'en étaient donc plus impérieux
mais vous en avez décidé autrement le
président a confisqué l'évaluation
stratégique préalable nécessaire à toute
LPM il l'a réduite à l'écriture en
cercle restreint d'une revue nationale
stratégique jusqu'ici sous la Cinquième
République les grands tournants de la
stratégie militaire française ont tous
été pris suite à la publication de
livres blancs je ne vous apprendrai pas
que les communistes constants et
cohérents attachés à une défense
nationale indépendante ont souvent fait
valoir des désaccords essentiels avec
les orientations de ces livres blancs
mais ces documents avaient au moins le
mérite de permettre un débat stratégique
national d'ampleur animée par une
commission dédiée associée pendant une
année entière la représentation par le
montant les grandes administrations de
l'État et les hiérarchies militaires la
plus rien une consultation confinant à
la parodie avec un questionnaire remis
aux commissions parlementaires 12 jours
avant le discours de Mont-de-Marsan
voilà la tare originelle de cette LPM
elle porte la marque d'un grave défaut
de conception démocratique pour cette
question préalable je m'en tiendrai à
trois critiques majeures et je tenterai
de vous convaincre chers collègues de la
nécessité de reprendre le débat sur
d'autres bases car une autre politique
de défense est possible pour notre pays
d'abord cette LPM nous éloigne des
objectifs de défense de la nation au
profit du choix de la guerre et en
l'occurrence de la guerre projetée hors
de nos frontières avoir une guerre
d'avance c'est votre nouveau mantra
derrière le panache apparent de cette
formule se cache un profondé fétisme un
choix dangereux pour la sécurité
collective on nous dit que la peine est
plus une option qu'il faut prendre place
dans la grande dérive militariste
mondiale c'est oublier toutes les leçons
du XXe siècle la militarisation et le
suarmement singulièrement en Europe ont
toujours préparé la guerre et bien pire
encore jamais la paix c'est oublier
toutes les leçons des 30 dernières
années après la chute du Mur le monde
n'a pas été en paix l'Occident a usé de
sa puissance pour multiplier les guerres
guerre du Golfe ex Yougoslavie
Afghanistan ira klebi Sahel pour quel
résultat le chaos l'insécurité
déstabilisation durable des états et la
militarisation des sociétés jamais la
paix durable c'est oublier enfin que la
guerre affame les peuples et nourrit les
fauteurs de guerre dans ce chaos
prolifèrent les monstres et les
entrepreneurs de violence terroristes
milice et sociétés privées trafic de
drogue et d'armes traite d'être humain
nationalisme guerriers et impérialisme
régionaux extrême droite éradicalisme
religieux le suarmement nourrit la
guerre il ne la désarme jamais les
arsenonucléaires prolifèrent à nouveau
le réarmement naval est à un niveau
inédit depuis 45 les budgets militaires
expo explosent en Europe comme au
Moyen-Orient et en Asie face à la Chine
les États-Unis veulent entraîner tous
leurs alliés dans un dangereux continuum
compétition économique guerre militaire
quant à la Russie elle s'enfonce dans
une guerre en Ukraine au coup humain
économique et militaires astronomique
aux conséquences imprévisibles pour
l'Europe et pour elle-même comme vient
le révéler l'incroyable épisode de la
rébellion Wagner quand allons-nous nous
réveiller quand allons-nous cesser cette
insupportable banalisation de la guerre
pour notre part nous appelons toutes les
consciences libres à Saint giorgés
contre cette folie car d'autres chemins
sont possibles pour le monde vous allez
me dire que nous sommes naïfs que la
menace est partout que la guerre en
Ukraine dit qui est l'ennemi et qu'il
faut bien riposter se réarmer dans tous
les domaines oui le monde a
effectivement changé et les menaces sont
nombreuses mais vous vous trompez sur le
diagnostic le diagnostic de ces
bouleversements et les moyens de
conjurer les menaces vous vous trompez
d'époque la guerre de Poutine en Ukraine
n'est pas le symptôme le symptôme du
retour des blocs d'hier c'est un signe
de plus de la décibilisation du monde
qu'entraîne la militarisation des
relations internationales et
l'affrontement de plus en plus violent
des logiques de puissance le chaos
mondial est paradoxalement le résultat
d'un monde plus interdépendant mais en
même temps toujours plus inégal pour
relever les grands défis mondiaux tout
appel le partage et les plus riches le
refusent la loi du plus fort la
puissance militaire ne règleront plus
les problèmes bien au contraire faut-il
suivre alors les États-Unis ou tout
autre d'ailleurs dans l'escalade
militaire faut-il les suivre quand ils
cherchent à déstabiliser toute puissance
émergente pour maintenir cul de coude
que coûte leur leadership planétaire
est-ce la voix que la France doit suivre
je ne le crois pas et c'est la deuxième
conviction que je veux partager avec
vous
la stratégie d'alignement derrière les
États-Unis et le bloc occidental que
poursuit des facto cette LPM est
dangereuse pour notre pays pour l'Europe
et pour la paix mondiale les paradoxes
apparents de la LPM souligné d'ailleurs
dans les débats de la commission des
affaires étrangères du Sénat n'en sont
pas dissuasion nucléaire porte-avion
espace fond marin dans tous les modes
domaines cette LPN court après la
sophistication militaire au risque d'y
perdre notre boussole et la mesure de
nos moyens réels et tout cela au titre
d'une haute intensité en vérité
uniquement entendu comme la capacité de
projection de nos armées dans des
opérations militaires de l'Otan hors de
nos frontières
l'intégralité du vocabulaire du concept
stratégique de l'OTAN révisé à Madrid et
d'ailleurs recyclé dans la LPM
l'autanisation complète de l'Europe est
en cours elle met à bas toute véléité
d'autonomie stratégique européenne elle
finance en premier lieu les industries
américaines de l'armement
le bloc atlantiste n'offre pourtant
qu'une cohérence de façade est incapable
d'enrayer les velléités bellicistes et
expansionnistes de certains de ses
membres la Turquie d'Erdogan à
l'opportunisme géopolitique décomplexée
en en l'exemple le plus criant et que
dire de nos alliés des monarchies du
Golfe que dire en Europe même de la
Hongrie de la Pologne de l'Italie et du
poids grandissant dans ces pays
d'extrême droite raciste et militariste
pour notre part nous vous proposons de
remettre la LPM en chantier car ces
objectifs se trompent de cibles sur le
monde à construire vous sautez comme des
cabris la guerre la guerre la guerre
mais vous ne voyez pas le Nouveau Monde
qui s'amon qui s'avance quand
accepterez-vous d'entendre qu'une
majorité de peuples du monde ne veut
plus avoir à s'affilier à tel ou telle
superpuissance les peuples aspirent à
maîtriser leur destin à disposer de
souveraineté pleines et entières a
décidé librement de leurs alliances et
coopération
vous restez accroché à vos vieux schémas
hors de l'OTAN vous ne voyez que la main
de Moscou ou celle de Pékin content de
pays en réalité cherche de nouveaux
partenariats plus équilibré comment
pouvez-vous ignorer que les insécurités
sanitaires alimentaires énergétiques
climatiques que l'absence de partage
réel de la gouvernance politique de la
mondialisation sont au cœur de tous les
conflits et par conséquent à la racine
de toutes les guerres entendez le
constat lucide du Secrétaire général de
l'ONU si nous nourrissons pas les gens
nous nourrissons les conflits vous
persistez à de nauséames avec des
mécanismes qui ont échoué à construire
la paix 20 ans de guerre au terrorisme
s'achève par le départ des troupes
américaines d'Afghanistan ont proie à la
famine ce pays est devenu un Arco état
pour financer la guerre sous domination
des talibans 10 ans de barkhane au Sahel
n'ont y éteint le djihadisme ni permis
le développement de la région il est
temps de changer de paradigme l'agenda
pour la paix et la sécurité collective
c'est la construction d'une sécurité
humaine globale répondant aux besoins
vitaux des populations leur permettant
de cohabiter en paix dans la durée et
autour de perspectives de développement
la France dispose encore d'une voix
écoutée dans le monde
utilisons-la pour relancer tous les
processus de désarmement multilatéraux
conventionnel comme nucléaire utilisons
là pour clamer le droit à la paix ce mot
que certains voudraient aujourd'hui
tabou jamais nous nous rallierons à
cette affirmation absurde selon laquelle
est désormais dépassé le temps des
dividendes de la paix mais non seulement
la paix n'a pas de prix mais elle est et
restera le sol horizon raisonnable pour
l'humanité c'est pourquoi constant et
cohérent nous serons tout au long de ces
débats animés par une double convection
garantir à notre pays une défense
souveraine et solide et agir en même
temps pour que grandissent partout des
coalitions de la paix je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
y a-t-il un orateur contre la motion
je n'en vois point
quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur le président
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je pense qu'il est utile de resituer
cette motion tendante à opposer la
question préalable au projet de loi de
programmation militaire dans son
contexte il y a un an à la fin du
printemps 2022 le président de la
République a estimé que l'agression de
l'Ukraine par la Russie était un
événement d'une telle ampleur
géopolitique qu'il imposait d'arrêter
prématurément la LPM 2019-2025 pour
adopter une nouvelle programmation
militaire chacun peut penser ce qu'il
veut de cette décision certains disaient
puisque la LPM précédente prévoit déjà
des marges d'augmentation de crédit à 3
milliards allons au bout de cet LPM et
nous en ferons une nouvelle en 2025
lorsqu'on aura une vision plus claire de
la situation nouvelle le projet de loi a
été déposé après une revue stratégique
qui n'a pas franchement convaincu ni par
sa méthode ni monsieur le ministre par
ces groupes de travail préparatoires à
la LPM au contour mal défini ni par son
calendrier parfois précipité ou en tous
les cas trop resserré pour permettre un
travail approfondi ni enfin par ses
conclusions succinctes qui n'aborent pas
la question fondamentale qui nous est
posée aujourd'hui quel modèle d'armée
voulons-nous pour la France pour les
années qui viennent ou pour dire les
choses en termes plus politiques et
moins militaires quel est notre ambition
pour la France dans un monde de plus en
plus instable et dangereux et avec quel
moyen
ces constater amène le groupe CRCE a
déposé une motion tendante à opposer la
question préalable la Commission ne la
votera pas et appelle bien évidemment le
Sénat à ne pas la voter et ce pour deux
raisons nos concitoyens s'attendent
légitimement alors que la guerre frappe
de nouveau le seul européen que nous
débattions sereinement des moyens mis à
la disposition de nos forces armées nos
armées attendent des adaptations
nécessaires pour se préparer à la haute
intensité et à l'hypothèse d'engagement
majeur
nos industriels ont besoin de visibilité
requises par l'émergence de la notion
d'économie de guerre ce que propose le
projet de loi enfin nos alliés nos
partenaires mais aussi nos compétiteurs
et sûrement nos adversaires sont
attentifs au signaux que nous enverrons
en examinant ce projet de loi le premier
signal sera celui d'un parlement investi
ce fut le cas à l'Assemblée nationale ce
sera aussi le cas au Sénat je crois que
nous pouvons raisonner l'armement dire
que nous n'avons que nous n'aurons
jamais autant préparé et aussi en amont
une LPM nous avons certes écarté la
méthode proposée par le gouvernement
mais le bureau de la commission avait
choisi de lancer pas moins de 7 rapports
d'informations je l'ai évoqué il y a un
instant sur la guerre du crâne barkhane
et chacun des programmes concernés et je
souhaite ici à nouveau rendre hommage à
toutes celles toutes celles et ceux
d'entre vous qui enrichit la réflexion
de la commission par ses rapports très
riches très fouillé et important
comme président de la commission je suis
évidemment fier des conditions dans
lequel a été menée ce travail colossal
je suis tout aussi fier de l'esprit dans
lequel ces travaux ont été menés fait du
respect de chacun et d'esprit
républicains qui a associé tous les
groupes je dis bien tous les groupes je
pense que cet esprit de responsabilité
se consensus républicain autour d'un
socle de valeurs partagées au-delà de
nos sensibilités politiques légitimes
c'est de la marque de fabrique du Sénat
et elle contribue au rayonnement de
notre assemblée nous sommes donc prêts
et nous avons débuté en commission le
travail d'examen du projet de LPM le 14
juin dernier deux commissions celle des
lois et des finances se sont saisies
pour avis nous avons adopté 171
amendements pour établir le texte de la
commission dont d'ailleurs 11
amendements du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes c'est
donc un texte déjà largement amélioré
par les commissions par les groupes
politiques dont nous allons sereinement
débattre et que nos armées attendent
elles en ont besoin nos différents donc
pas le débat et le travail parlementaire
sur ce texte essentiel dans un contexte
géopolitique si différent et si
dangereux par rapport à ce qu'il était
en 2018 lorsque nous avons voté la
précédente LPM je conclue donc bien
évidemment au rejet de cette question
préalable déposée par le groupe CRCA je
vous remercie merci
oui monsieur le Président du Sénat
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mesdames messieurs et sénateurs monsieur
le Président Laurent pour le
gouvernement c'est un avis évidemment
défavorable et une demande que le Sénat
rejette cette cette question préalable
tout simplement parce qu'elle n'aurait
qu'un seul effet c'est de ne pas
permettre le débat et si j'en crois ce
qui a été dit à de nombreuses reprises
en commission dont vous êtes membre
d'ailleurs par ailleurs ce qui est dit
si vous la dans la presse à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est que la démocratie
représentative précisément elle a besoin
de s'emparer de ce sujet de cette
question du modèle de sécurité
collective que nous voulons défendre
alors après que nous soyons pas d'accord
sur la dissuasion nucléaire que nous
soyons pas d'accord sur nos alliances
que nous soyez pas d'accord sur les
coopérations industrielles que ne soyons
pas d'accord sur le modèle économique de
nos industries ça sera le temps du débat
mais adopter cette question préalable
c'est tout simplement mettre quelque
part au classeur cylindrique
pardonnez-moi cette expression c'est toi
le programmation militaire dont
malheureusement nous ne pourrons pas
opposer une question préalable aux
menaces qui pèse sur la nation française
et elles sont d'actualité c'était dit
par le président Cambon il y a une
opération stratégique parfois pour
remettre au goût du jour malheureusement
des problèmes sécuritaires que nous
connaissions jadis du temps de la guerre
froide ou des questions qui sont posées
autour de la prolifération nucléaire
parfois certaines menaces continuent
malheureusement de se faire sous nos
yeux et plus personne n'en parle
suffisamment et je le redis merci pour
le débat qui a été demandé par le groupe
socialiste sur l'Afrique puisque la
question de terroriste doit continuer à
nous mobiliser il faudra bien qu'on y
apporte des réponses et qu'on continue
d'y apporter des réponses que nous avons
pardon mais des sauts technologiques
c'est pas une affaire de choix
politiques c'est tout simplement que
c'est saut technologique s'impose à nous
la militarisation du cyber on ne peut
pas d'un côté déplorer les attaques que
les différents hôpitaux français ont pu
connaître sur un terrain plutôt
cybercriminalité et ne pas voir que
demain le cyber a une utilisation et
évidemment une traduction en matière
militaire on ne peut pas ne pas voir la
militarisation de l'espace que l'on peut
regretter sur le terrain des valeurs
mais qui néanmoins va s'imposer à nous y
compris sur l'ensemble de nos
infrastructures civiles la question des
fonds sous la guerre des mines bref
autant de sujets dont il était peu
question dans cette hémicycle en 2018 et
pour cause puisque les technologies nous
ont rattrapé et c'est ce qui explique
aussi ce pourquoi nous nous retrouvons
avant même le terme de programmation
militaire actuelle puisque au-delà même
de la guerre en Ukraine un certain
nombre d'éléments nous conduisent à de
nouveaux solliciter la représentation
nationale et pas que pour une
trajectoire budgétaire et pas que pour
des aspects normatifs mais aussi pour
soumettre des orientations politiques
nouvelles qui pivote en quelque sorte
aussi pour notre modèle d'armée
j'ajouterai aussi pardon mais que ce
texte comprend des mesures qu'on
pourrait qualifier de social pour la
troupe revalorisation des grilles
indiciaires indemnitaires je vois mal
comment le gouvernement aurait pu les
mettre en oeuvre en loi de finances sans
repasser par une mise à jour à minimale
à la programmation militaire et mieux
une nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire c'est ce que nous faisons donc
demande de rejet et d'opposer justement
à cette question préalable le fait de
pouvoir conduire un débat
sur lequel on pourra examiner l'ensemble
des amendements y compris les vôtres et
qui permettra de mieux redessiner des
modèles de sécurité qui certes nous
seront peut-être pas les mêmes je les
dis moi-même je l'ai pris les devants à
la tribune mais qui au moins viendront
aussi nourrir la méthodologie qui a été
la nôtre merci au président comment
d'avoir dit que jamais une LPM n'a été
autant préparé certes pas comme
d'habitude on y reviendra mais au moins
pour le coup il y a un foisonnement de
contribution les rapports parlementaires
ont tous été intégrés aussi dans la
réflexion globale et moi je serai
défendre les choix militaires qui ont
été retenus proposés par les États
majeurs au président de la République et
tel que vous les retrouvez dans un
programmation tel que vous est soumise
demande de rejet
merci explication de vote je rappelle
qu'il y a une explication de votre par
groupe monsieur et
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur
président de commission monsieur
rapporteur mes chers collègues notre
groupe voudrait mettre en exergue un
certain nombre d'éléments qui permettent
de s'opposer à cette motion
tendant à opposer la question préalable
tout d'abord lorsqu'on parle de
d'immaturité du texte je voudrais
rappeler que ce texte il a été élaboré
sous l'autorité déjà du président de la
République chef des armées dans la
concertation en étroite relation avec
les militaires la Direction générale de
l'armement avec les directions de
nombreux ministères en raison de sa
transversalité mais aussi très en amont
et je tiens ici à saluer votre démarche
monsieur le ministre avec nos deux
chambres du Parlement et les acteurs du
monde de la défense en général ce texte
il cherche également à répondre à un
enjeu fort de sécurité de souveraineté
et à traduire une convection simple
celle des menaces qui pèsent sur la
nation et qui n'ont jamais été aussi
protéiforme qu'elles ne le sont
actuellement
a bien des égards elle place la France
face à des filles majeure qui oblige à
anticiper et à prévoir ces lois de
programmation militaires nous obligent à
bien des égards mais je retiendrai
personnellement deux points qui me
semblent particulièrement important de
souligner tout d'abord il s'agit d'une
voie de programmation qui comme son nom
l'indique va se mettre en place de
manière cohérente posée sur un certain
nombre d'années la programmation et le
geste stratégique par excellence nous
indiquait dernièrement le président à
Mont-de-Marsan je crois qu'aucune
politique sérieuse ne peut se passer de
vision à long terme il faut voir loin et
les enjeux et défilent aujourd'hui
justifiant les efforts qu'il nous faut
mener demain et nous oblige également au
regard des sommes engagées 413 milliards
d'euros ce n'est pas rien et si ce
chiffre peut parfois être critiqué
discuté tiraillés tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il ne s'agit pas de
dépenses passives il faut rééquiper et
moderniser nos armées leur donner des
capacités de se défendre et d'agir dans
des champs hybrides espaces fonds marins
cyber en incluant les fonds
international pour tous ces pour toutes
ces différentes raisons ces différents
éléments notre groupe s'opposera à la
motion tendance à s'opposer à la
question préalable je vous remercie
pas d'autres demandes d'explication de
vote je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
motion tendance à opposer la question
préalable je rappelle que l'adoption de
cette notion entraînerait le rejet du
texte en discussion
qui est pour cette notion
avec contraire
et n'est pas adopté
dans la suite de notre discussion
générale je vais donner la parole de
notre collègue rachité mal pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous sommes donc réunis
aujourd'hui pour évoquer la loi de
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 2030 permettez-moi tout d'abord à
cette occasion de saluer l'engagement le
professionnalisme des femmes et des
hommes qui composent nos forces armées
qui parfois malheureusement connaissent
la mort et pour défendre la foi je l'ai
dit notre pays et nos intérêts vitaux je
vais essayer de résumer mon propos en
trois points d'abord le contexte de
cette loi de programmation militaire
ensuite bien évidemment son contenu et
ensuite j'ai envie de dire le travail du
Sénat puisque nous reviendrons sur
effectivement ce que nous avons emporté
collectivement
vous évoquez tout à l'heure le fait
d'une loi de programmation militaire
c'est effectivement à la fois un temps
long on sait quand on lance des
programmes c'est parfois pour 30 40 50
ans et en même temps relativement court
et d'ailleurs nous sommes en secret dans
la puisque parfois d'une prise en une
autre il faut revoir cette loi de
programmation militaire parfois il est
effectivement de la revoir de la
reconstruire de l'imaginer un nouveau et
pour cela permettez-moi de revenir sur
quelques dates pour dire comment le
monde peut changer en 30 ans et se dire
comment se fait la projection
d'abord effectivement beaucoup de gens
et l'évocent ils voulaient voter ce
ministre sur les 10 ans de la paix aussi
le monsieur le rapporteur mais là aussi
je crois que c'était une réalité pour
tout le monde pour tous les bancs de
tous les hémicycles quand le mur est
tombé le 9 novembre 1989 je crois que
chacun
légitimement a pu penser que d'ailleurs
c'était même théorie sur la fin de
l'histoire que un nouveau temps pouvait
s'ouvrir et ce temps là c'était celui de
la démocratie en tout cas sur le
continent africain et la capacité à être
dans une autre logique
chacun peut voir depuis la suite autre
date sur lequel je veux m'arrêter un
instant c'est également sur le 11
septembre 2001 effectivement c'est un
temps qui vient gravement perturber on
le voit vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
la question est terrorisme d'abord dans
une forme que nous avons vu je l'ai dit
le 11 septembre des attentats aussi en
Europe et dans le monde occidental j'ai
envie de dire mais également des
terroristes qui continuent à perturber
encore et encore on voit sur la question
de l'Afrique vous l'avez évoqué on
l'évoquera tout à l'heure sur la
question de barkham sur la question la
présence en cours de la France en
Afrique sur la question du redéploiement
de nos bases
et puis aussi le 15 août 2021 le départ
des troupes d'attente américaine du de
Kaboul parce que là aussi c'est un sujet
aussi important je crois qu'on a peut
passer sous les radars c'est la question
de l'implantation et de la conviction
de cette force qui sont les États-Unis
d'être ou non dans une logique à la fois
d'être et c'est toujours leur
réflexion être dans le monde ou être
dans leur frontière et ça c'est un
élément aussi que nous devons garder à
l'esprit au-delà de simplement d'une
élection présidentielle et son
présidentielle mais ça veut dire quelle
est leur volonté autre date le 24
février 2022 je l'avouerais tout à
l'heure bien sûr c'est la question de
clashement de la guerre en Ukraine avec
pour la première fois une force dotée de
l'arme nucléaire qui décide sur le
compte africain de passer ses frontières
de semer le doute le chaos avec les
conséquences que nous connaissons et
puis une date peut-être pour l'avenir
j'ai envie de parler de du de l'année
2049 c'est le standard de la République
populaire de Chine mais c'est également
la question
de son rapport à Taïwan et donc ça nous
renvoie la question d'entre aujourd'hui
et 2049 sur la position de la Chine
chacun a pu entendre des déclarations du
président premiers secrétaire du parti
chinois par ailleurs responsable des
forces armées mais son annonce très
clair
avant 2049 Taïwan sera chinois et donc
sur la poinçon de question et quand on
disons on dit cela c'est effectivement
la cité de revoir l'évolution du monde
et moi je comprends
qu'il faille revoir notre loi de
programmation militaire et donc chacun
peut imaginer effectivement je crois
qu'il y a un travail pédagogique doit
être fait j'en dirai un mot tout à
l'heure sur ce qu'est le monde
d'aujourd'hui et là je ne parle encore
que quelques dates on y ajoute bien
évidemment la question des états des
empires contrarié la Chine la Russie je
rappelle que depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois plusieurs années les rencontres
entre les deux dirigeants sont massives
sont régulières on le voit d'ailleurs
maintenant ce qui se passe sur la guerre
en Ukraine sur les liens entre les deux
pays
et à part cela c'est vrai qu'il nous
faut réfléchir cette façon là donc les
empires contrarié j'ajouterai bien sûr
la Turquie on voit bien d'ailleurs qui
aujourd'hui avec la réélection
malheureusement de son président cette
volonté de pousser les pions on le voit
notamment sur le continent africain que
ce soit en Libye ou ailleurs
en Ukraine c'est vrai que la donne a
beaucoup changé puisqu'on le voit je
l'ai dit un pays doté de l'arme
nucléaire décide d'envahir
qui parfois fait pour le président
nucléaire à l'armement nucléaire nous
avons aussi une réflexion sur les
conflits d'eau d'intensité sur également
nos armes diverses et variées qui sont
aussi positionnés
j'ajoute un opacifique nous avons quand
même plusieurs questions sur ce volet là
d'abord nous avons une question de même
de présence française quand j'envoie les
résultats électoraux en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et dans la
dopacifique et également je l'ai dit la
volonté chinoise de pousser les pions
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur des niveaux
de construction par exemple la flotte
chinoise fait seulement la moitié
seulement de la flotte la flotte
américaine on voit les progressions sur
les dans les mers sur sur les aires à
volonté chinoise et donc se pose la
question la France qui je rappelle est
la seule puissance européenne soit un
continent de France indopacifique se
pose la question de son rôle de sa
présence de non pas de sa capacité à
porter le faire le cas échéant au niveau
de la Chine bien évidemment mais en tout
cas de protéger ses territoires et sa
zone économique spéciale qu'il a plus
vaste du monde je crois que c'est
vraiment qu'il faut apporter et cette la
volonté que nous avons c'est cette loi
de programmation militaire il répond
j'ajoute un mot sur le continent
africain
[Musique]
et puis pour ne pas être trop long je
pourrais évoquer bien sûr la
prolifération nucléaire etc mais je
voudrais dire un mot aussi sur la
question du Sud global puisque c'est la
première LPM aussi ou pour la première
fois et on l'a vu à l'occasion
d'ailleurs du vote des différents votes
aux Nations Unies sur la question de
l'Ukraine pour la première fois ce qu'on
appelle le sud global a décidé de ne pas
suivre et ne pas voter ne pas condamner
l'invasion de la Russie en Ukraine
qui décide ce truc global de changer les
normes en disant que les règles
occidentales sont trop importantes ce
Sud global qui décide dorénavant d'avoir
sa propre monnaie et on voit bien que la
question de la puissance occidentale
aussi militaire maintenant et largement
posé
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça sur ce
contexte là quelques mots sur la loi de
programmation vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre c'est la 15e
alors vous citez souvent le général de
Gaulle et comme je vous le dis à chaque
fois on peut parfois comment
tout à fait mais vous essayez souvent en
général et je vous le dis à chaque fois
on peut être à la fois golien sur cette
gaulliste
et donc c'est vrai qu'on peut satisfaire
effectivement du choix j'ai relu
d'ailleurs la LPM du général de Gaulle
convenons-en c'était d'un autre niveau
que celle que nous avons aujourd'hui
devant nous mais
ce n'est pas un souci en cela mais comme
vous le savez aussi
ce qui a fait que l'alpm les LPM et la
logique notamment dissuasion nucléaire
et d'armes conventionnelles a aussi pu
être poursuivi sélection de 1980 puisque
là aussi François Mitterrand a fait le
choix lui aussi
de totalement porté ce concept là
d'ailleurs en allant jusqu'au bout de la
saison nucléaire en expliquant que ce
qui faisait la force de son nucléaire
c'était le président de la République le
reste l'été de choses n'étaient que
matière inerte et donc je le dis comme
ça parce que je sais souvent que vous
citez le général de rappeler que ma
famille politique François Hollande
François Hollande en dernier a juste
avant et encore François Mitterrand ont
été aussi les artisans fortement
importants d'une dissuasion nucléaire
d'une armée à la hauteur des enjeux et
de la défense de notre territoire je
crois que c'est important de le rappeler
mais pour ne pas être trop long sur ces
questions là
comme l'ont dit certains de mes
collègues le souci avec cette LPM c'est
que le Sénat est aujourd'hui un peu
inquiet interrogatif parfois chaciné
parce que nous avons l'espace de
l'actuel loi de la programmation
militaire d'abord parce que certains
l'ont dit nous avons souhaité une remise
à jour elle nous a été refusée il faut
le dire
nous avons souhaité dans la construction
de la nouvelle que le pardon puisseger
tout son rôle ça nous a pas été possible
puisque encore une fois il n'y a pas eu
de livre blanc il y a une revue
nationale stratégique fait en chambre
sans le Parlement et c'est vrai que le
Parlement bien sûr fait la loi mais
aussi à la question du contrôle du
gouvernement et sur l'évaluation des
politiques publiques
une fois je vous dis ça je pourrais
évoquer la question au financière alors
je pourrais vous parler de 2% je
pourrais vous parler des 7 milliards je
pourrais parler 13 milliards chacun mais
je vais dire un mot quand même sur le
montage financier
parce que si on prend les 413 milliards
mettons de côté les 13 milliards il nous
reste 400 milliards de crédits
budgétaires convenait avec moi que
l'année 24 25 qui devait être qui sont
dans laquelle VPN c'est grosso modo 97
milliards qu'on compte quasiment deux
fois si j'ajoute à ça les 30 milliards
d'inflation je mets de côté à ce stade
les 100 milliards de reparts de charges
convenait avec moi que les besoins de
financement seront quand même réels
devant nous et j'ajouterai pourrai pas
faire trop long que nous aurons une
excentrentiel en 2017 en 2027 et force
est à parier parce que la conscience est
assez rédigée même si je crois que
certains va changer je crois pas que ce
sera le cas nous aurons un nouveau une
nouvelle présidente qui est aussi fera
une nouvelle programmation militaire et
par ailleurs pour pas être trop long sur
ce studio d'aspect là des choses vous
savez bien que quand on y ajoutera le
fait que
la facture sera payée par la suivante
majorité vous voyez que ça est un peu
plus complexe mais moi ce qui me choque
ou ce qui me pose problème à ce stade
je crois qu'il faut être honnête une
autre majorité aurait également eu une
armée complète c'est ce que nous
souhaitons dissuasion conventionnelle il
n'y a pas de sujet là dessus chacun est
tenu par les finances publiques donc
nous serions à peu près dans les murs et
donc se pose la question certains diront
une arme est complète et miniature un
bonsaï chacun il mettra les mots qu'il
souhaite donc la question à partir de là
c'est notre capacité agir seul ou j'ai
envie de dire accompagner et je trouve
et c'est là d'ailleurs que j'ai le
regret sur le livre blanc c'est que nous
ne pouvons pas voir dans ce cadre là le
vrai débat à mon sens c'est que doit
faire la France pour maintenir sa
capacité de défense et d'armement quel
rapport effectivement au loto et on le
voit ces derniers jours
moi je suis pour une grande part avec
mon groupe favorable elle est beaucoup
plus loin dans l'OTAN et je le dis être
dans le temps ce n'est pas réduire son
indépendance ce n'est pas réduire sa
capacité à agir ce n'est pas réduire sa
capacité à décider ce n'est pas mettre
en partage la dissuasion nucléaire bien
au contraire mais quand je vois les
Allemands qui ces derniers jours ont été
pilotes pour la question de la
protection sur le j'ai envie de dire le
la protection anti-missile vous voyez
bien c'est ce que devrait faire la
France et c'est dommage qu'on puisse pas
le faire dans un texte législatif c'est
à dire comment on soit on soit leader
dans l'OTAN la forme de grandes
questions puisque on peut avoir sur le
débat sur la question européenne j'y
reviendrai mais sur la question de temps
je crois que c'est un manque monsieur le
ministre dans nos débats il n'est pas
possible parce que c'est un texte de loi
il aurait été possible ces environs une
vraie un vrai livre blanc sur la
question européenne je crois qu'il faut
aussi l'assumer
il ne faut pas il faut une politique
urbaine défense beaucoup plus importante
là aussi ne c'est pas possible dans ce
texte sur les questions de recherche
développement sur les questions
notamment de commandes communes ou de
projets communs d'armement je crois que
la suite il faut porter les choses pour
ne pas être trop long je vous dirai un
mot également sur contrôle par
lamentaire beaucoup de choses oui nous
avons souhaité renforcer cela avec la
commission nous avons travaillé
parfaitement avec le président Cambon et
l'ensemble des commissaires et je les
remercie de cela c'est vrai que quand le
parlementaire est important pour nous
alors c'est vrai que nous avons fait
adopter un amendement notamment sur la
question d'un ouvrier blanc alors j'ai
compris que parfois dans les troupes ça
posait ceci appelons-le livre bleu ou
Apollo autrement mais la question qu'à
un moment donné on puisse nous Parlement
faire nos travail il n'est pas normal
qu'on te demande de tarif le prix d'un
porte-avion qu'à ce stade de moins était
faite au ministre demandait fait de
Shelta major des armées n'avons pas
toujours de mon temps et donc il est
important de nous suivre réellement les
programmes militaires
alors parce que le temps maintenant peut
être réduit pour terminer mais on aura
l'occasion de débattre encore dans nos
débats vous dire que la position des
socialistes pour notre groupe on l'a dit
depuis le début la question c'est de
bonifier la LPM et je crois je parle ce
contrôle du président Cambon que par nos
amendements en commission nous avons su
bonifier ce texte l'article premier
beaucoup d'autres textes je vous le dis
sur un centre de questions sur on
reviendra dessus sur le SNU sur la
question du contrôle j'ai envie de
l'armement sur bien évidemment la
question aussi la question sociale pour
pour les militaires vous voyez que nous
avons essaiement progressé et et aussi
sur la question de la puissance
d'équilibre ou
l'acquisition d'influence voilà beaucoup
d'éléments sur lequel nous avons fait
progresser ce texte nous souhaitons nous
l'avons lu ce matin à l'interview dans
le Figaro monsieur le ministre oui nous
avons fait beaucoup d'amendements et ce
n'est pas parce qu'on n'avons pas
c'était pas des idées comme cela c'est
parce que nous souhaitons qu'on
construit avec vous la question de
défense nationale parce que il y aura
une nouvelle majorité en 2027 nous
espérons en être pour pouvoir avoir
aussi d'autres visions sur la question
militaire mais donc nous attendons
maintenant beaucoup effectivement de la
sagesse voir le soutien du gouvernement
sur le bon nombre d'amendements vous
verrez qu'ils ne font que bonifier cette
ex là et je crois que c'est la demande
de l'ensemble des bancs du Sénat
bonifions ce texte là améliorons notre
texte faisant en sorte que notre pays
puisse avoir son armée à son niveau et
que nos hommes et nos femmes qui la
composent soient fiers de porter notre
uniforme et porter nos couleurs je vous
remercie
merci je vais appeler Madame Michel
gréaume pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre Michel collègue l'enjeu de ce
projet de loi en définissant la
trajectoire budgétaire de nos armées
pour les 7 prochaines années et timorce
malheureusement cette loi fut décidée à
la hâte deux ans avant la fin de
l'actuel LPM et ne dispose d'aucune
orientation stratégique précise juste
celle d'une obligatoire augmentation des
dépenses militaires dans un contexte
marqué par des logiques de puissance et
parfois de remise en cause des principes
du droit international le sujet dont
traite ce projet de loi aurait dû
associer bien plus largement la
représentation nationale mais une fois
de plus elle furent décidées par un seul
homme il est ainsi acté de maintenir le
moderniser nos deux composantes de
dissuasion nucléaire sans que ces choix
n'aient été préalablement réévalués
outre l'opacité totale sur les
programmes précis des 53,7 milliards
consacrés aux armes à destruction
massive soit 13% du budget de la SPM
vous refusez tout débat sur la
pertinence stratégique du maintien d'une
telle stratégie de dissuasion moderniser
de tel système d'armes c'est engager la
France dans une stratégie pour des
décennies qui pourraient devenir
obsolètes en une monsieur le ministre ce
Paris est beaucoup trop lourd de
conséquences pour être décidé sans
concertation avec la représentation
nationale ne balayez pas nos
interrogations en faisant croire à nos
concitoyens qu'en matière de dissuasion
maintenu nucléaire nous serions face à
un choix binaire entre le tout et de
rien ce choix de la dissuasion pour
assurer la sanctuarisation de notre
territoire induit à notre choix très
discutable privilégiez l'équipement de
nos forces conventionnelles vers des
stratégies de projection extérieure il
serait sans doute tant de cesser de voir
la défense de notre pays partout
ailleurs qu'en France ce modèle de
projection au détriment de la défense de
nos territoires à des implications
stratégiques concrètes et de leur coût
budgétaire d'une part stratégique
puisque malgré les éléments de langage
creux du type la cohérence sur la masse
en réalité ce que je vois ce sont des
vides Capac qui perdure et une logique
échantillonnaire qui resterait la place
excessive accordée à la dissuasion
nucléaire conduit à opérer des coupes
claires dans nos défenses
opérationnelles or de quel conflit
souhaitez-vous nous réunir avec 200
chars Leclerc lorsque l'on sait que la
Russie en a perdu plus de 2000 depuis
son conflit en Ukraine quel territoire
maritime sur les 11 millions de
kilomètres carrés que contre la France
pourrions-nous surveiller ou défendre
avec une dizaine de bâtiments de premier
rang le paradoxe est trop logique
présente des coûts objets utilitaires
colossaux par exemple nous allons
dépenser plus de 10 milliards d'euros
dans un porte-avion faire valoir de
puissance ce bâtiment ne sera en aucun
cas utile en cas de guerre du fait de sa
trop grande vulnérabilité il mobilisera
davantage son groupe aéronaval pour sa
défense que pour celle de la nation vous
justifiez ce choix par le besoin de
puissance et par celui de pérenniser la
filière industrielle de nos chaudières
nucléaires à usage militaire d'autres
sont possibles et à quoi sert de se
doter aujourd'hui d'un nouvel d'un
nouveau porte-avion si ce n'est caressé
dans le sens du poil l'imaginaire
collectif du symbole de l'Est ou de
warente en réalité il s'agit de pouvoir
intégrer une tasse que forte américaine
et avoir l'illusion de la commander
pendant quelques jours sous les trois
tutelles d'un commandement américain
alors oui nombreux sont ceux qui
pointent les pays qui est qui ayant une
ambition navale construite des
porte-avions mais chers collègues en
faire de même est-ce pour autant
répondre avec pertinence et réalise mon
défi de sécurité qui sont et seront les
nôtres privés de réflexions stratégiques
souveraines vous ne faites que Mimi
celles des autres vous vous alignez sur
une course mondiale à l'armement qui
atteint les 2240 milliards de dollars
l'année dernière non instruit
manifestement de cette stratégie qui
vise pour garantir son hégémonie à
imprimer un rythme que les autres ne
pourront pas suivre vous vous alignez
sur les injonctions de l'OTAN de monter
le budget de défense à 2% du PIB et si
cet indicateur n'a aucune signification
militaire pour la défense de notre
nation puisque l'objectif absolu c'est
de pouvoir se gargariser d'être l'élève
modèle des Américains en réalité ce
déficit de viser stratégique menace
directement notre sécurité notre
souveraineté d'abord nous pensons que la
défense de la patrie passe d'abord et
avant tout par la promotion de la paix
une paix durable une paix qui
s'inscrivent en écho au désastre des
guerres or en s'alignant sur des
intérêts qui ne sont ni les siens ni
ceux participant à la sécurité humaine
la France se détourne de son engagement
indéfectible pour la paix et le libre
développement de tous les peuples
troisième réseau diplomatique au monde
notre nation doit s'inscrire dans une
visée stratégique globale visant à
prévenir les conflits à multiplier les
accords multilatéraux de désarmement
nucléaires et de démilitarisation des
espaces communs la revue nationale
stratégique a cru la diplomatie dans le
champ de l'influence et bien soit
ouvrons avec toutes les nations qui le à
travers l'ONU à travers des coopérations
à lutter contre les insécurités globales
et notamment l'une des plus menaçantes
la sécurité environnementale qui elle et
nous en avons la certitude Rhône entier
de notre territoire et causera une
catastrophe systémique pour l'humanité
ensuite je voudrais évoquer les lacunes
de la politique cyberte qui témoignent
des impensées stratégiques flagrantes de
cette LPM plusieurs types de luttes
informatiques sont assurés mais quid des
couches intermédiaires du numérique dans
la production des logiciels des systèmes
d'exploitation quid de la production des
matériels des routeurs au
microprocesseurs ou même des
infrastructures réseaux la commission de
la défense du Sénat des États-Unis
avaient déjà établi en 2012 que des
millions de composants électroniques
contrefaits ou compromis avaient pénétré
les systèmes d'âmes de leur pays au
regard des ruptures technologiques à
l'oeuvre aujourd'hui qui ont tous pour
une pour baisse commune une hyper
technologie et par la même une demande
croissante à la matière de composants
électronique de se résigner à ne pas
maîtriser souverainement les outils de
conception et de production du numérique
c'est se résigner à perdre notre auto
notre autonomie stratégique alors que le
gouvernement s'apprête à faire 10
milliards d'euros de coups de rabots
dans les crédits budgétaires cette loi
en hausse de 40% par rapport à la
précédente nous répond pas à l'unique
objectif qui devrait préoccuper nos
armées celle de l'Afrique défense de nos
territoires nous continuons nous
continuerons à nous éparpiller dans
toutes les régions du globe afin
d'assouvir des intérêts étrangers à la
France et contraire aux enjeux de
sécurité globale qui préoccupe
l'humanité pour toutes ces raisons notre
groupe votre raconte ce but ce projet de
loi et à travers une quarantaine
d'amendements nous vous donnerons le
détaillerons nos propositions afin
d'exprimer clairement notre vision d'une
France souveraine capable de se défendre
et promouvant la paix merci
merci cher collègue la parole est à
présent à Monsieur Olivier sigolotti
pour l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame Monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président la
Commission mes chers collègues
413 milliards c'est bien l'effort
budgétaires que prévoit cette loi de
programmation militaire pour la période
2024 2030 depuis plusieurs décennies
dans un contexte post guerre froide
bénéficiant des dividendes de la paix
nos forces se sont vues imposées une
érosion des moyens budgétaires et une
diminution drastique des effectifs cette
augmentation de la part du budget de la
Nation consacrée à nos armées elle a
bienvenu elle poursuit le mouvement
engagé dès 2019 avec la précédente LPM
qui avait déjà pour objectif de porter
la part des dépenses militaires à 2% du
PIB en 2025 et de créer 6000 emplois
cette trajectoire budgétaire de
croissance visait déjà régénérer le
capital opérationnel des armées pour
constituer une première étape vers un
modèle d'armée complet et équilibré
en février 2022 l'agression de l'Ukraine
par la Russie a constitué un glissement
stratégique la guerre était de retour
sur le flanc oriental de l'Europe et il
apparaissait nécessaire de revoir notre
ambition face à un regain de tension
dans toutes les zones du Monde ainsi les
risques et les menaces sont plus
importants que jamais et pourrait aller
jusqu'à un engagement de très haute
intensité
les travaux de cette nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire ont été engagées
depuis de nombreux mois et
malheureusement
l'exécutif a préféré faire l'économie
d'un livre blanc au profit d'une revue
nationale stratégique à laquelle les
parlementaires n'ont été que peu pour ne
pas dire pas associer ce que nous
regrettons
cette revue nationale stratégique se
limite malheureusement un inventaire des
défis sécurités futurs sans les
hiérarchiser alors que nos évoluons dans
un monde de plus en plus complexe marqué
par de nouveaux espaces de
conflictualité mais aussi par la
persistance de certains réflexes
comparables à ceux des derniers conflits
mondiaux nous sommes étonnés en
commission de constater que malgré une
hausse considérable du budget des armées
octroyées par cette loi de programmation
militaire certains objectifs sont bien
plus étalés qu'initialement que prévu et
nous regrettons également certains
décalages de programmes et même parfois
des révisions à la baisse nous nous
félicitons cependant des avancées
majeures désormais introduites dans ce
texte et des crédits fléchés sur des
programmes à effet majeurs comme sur des
cibles au combien importantes nous nous
réjouissons bien évidemment de
l'engagement du programme dédié aux
porte-avions de nouvelles générations
qui constituera un élément de
crédibilité de souveraineté et des 5
milliards d'ores et déjà fléchés dans
cette LPM
même si l'inflation impactera cette
trajectoire budgétaire nous ne pouvons
que saluer les efforts réalisés pour nos
services de renseignement et la lutte
contre l'ingérance pour nos forces
spéciales afin de leur permettre
d'améliorer encore leurs capacité et
leur polyvalence pour notre capacité de
dissuasion aérienne ou océanique qui
bénéficieront également de crédits
modernisation pour la consolidation du
socle d'entraînement grâce aux capacités
de simulation pour l'effort en faveur
des munitions qui permettra aux armées
de consolider et de recompléter les
stocks de munitions pour favoriser
également une transition nécessaire vers
les futurs capacités feu dans la
profondeur ou encore munitions
téléopérée pour les crédits accordés à
l'innovation au combien vitaux pour
affirmer nos supériorité technologique
et garantir la maîtrise des nouveaux
champs de conflictualité enfin pour
notre modèle RH et pour l'attention
portée à nos services de soutien
dans ce contexte notre groupe soutient
le lissage et la consolidation de la
trajectoire budgétaire ainsi que les
amendements venant sécuriser le budget
du ministère notre Commission a
également répondu à un appel des
industriels de la Défense et de leurs
prestataires rencontrant encore souvent
et trop souvent des difficultés de
financement en créant le livret
souveraineté en tant que rapporteur pour
avis du programme 178 lors de l'examen
du budget je ne peux m'empêcher
d'évoquer quelques points l'effort
consenti en faveur des crédits de
paiement dans le cadre de cette LPM et
conséquent trois chiffres marquent une
progression très nette
69 milliards d'euros bénéficieront à
l'entraînement et à l'activité des
forces soit un effort supplémentaire par
rapport à la précédente LPM de 20
milliards 49 milliards sont alloués à
l'entretien programmé du matériel soit
14 milliards de plus et en fin 18
milliards pour les services de soutien
ce sont 4 milliards supplémentaires les
forêts là il était indispensable tant le
programme 178 et dimensionnant pour
répondre à l'hypothèse d'engagement
majeur comme à la haute intensité mais
les résultats en matière préparation
opérationnelle et de disponibilités
techniques représente de fortes
préoccupations pour notre commission et
en 2023 les indicateurs à la matière
sont parfois particulièrement décevants
la situation s'est dégradée sans que
nous n'ayons aucune visibilité sur le
décrochage qui s'est opérée pendant les
quatre premières années de la LPM faute
d'application de l'article 7 qui devait
fixer les objectifs annuels dans ces
domaines
nous nous assurerons également que les
indicateurs de l'armée de terre qui
n'atteignent aujourd'hui que 70% de la
norme d'entraînement ne soient pas
sous-estimés la consommation de ces
crédits ne devra pas donc être repoussée
à la deuxième moitié ou au dernier tiers
de cette LPM et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter cette fois encore de ne pas
avoir les jalons tout au long de
l'exécution d'ellepm nous aurons très
certainement le débat en séance nous
devons collectivement veiller au capital
technique de nos armées nous ne pouvons
pas comme certaines nos alliés nous
retrouver avec une armée qui présente
bien mais qui s'effrite lors d'un examen
détaillé le groupe Union centriste
portera avec convictions plusieurs
amendements sur le service de santé des
armées afin que le ministère des armées
s'engage après à préserver leur
savoir-faire parfois unique au monde ou
sur les grands fonds marins qui
constituent un nouvel espace de
conflictualité
il y a un an le Sénat a rendu un rapport
sur cette problématique des grands fonds
marins où il indiquait qu'à ce jour la
marine ne disposait d'aucun équipement
propre capable d'atteindre 6000 mètres
de profondeur il est nécessaire que
l'objectif d'acquisition d'équipements
spécifiques pour mieux connaître
surveiller et agir jusqu'à des
profondeurs importantes soit poursuivies
et atteints cela permettrait de couvrir
près de 97% des fonds marins du globe
pour la France dans la superficie
maritime représente 17 fois la
superficie terrestre grâce à ces
outre-mer il s'agit de préserver son
rôle historique de grande puissance
militaire et scientifique au niveau
mondial nous avons également déposé de
nombreux amendements sur l'importance de
la filière stratégique des drones enfin
nous soutiendrons les amendements visant
à consolider notre BITD mon collègue
Philippe Folliot insistera pour sa part
dans quelques instants sur tous les
enjeux liés à nos outre-mer et portés
par le groupe Union centriste
enfin pour conclure j'aimerais avoir une
pensée pour les soldats tombés pour
notre drapeau ou qui ont été blessés sur
les différents théâtres d'opérations
extérieures et particulièrement pour les
58 soldats qui ont perdu la vie durant
l'opération barkhane monsieur le
ministre durant l'examen de ce texte
structurant pour nos forces nous avons
le devoir ensemble de déterminer le
modèle d'armée que nous souhaitons pour
faire face aux enjeux de souveraineté
auxquels la France doit répondre à
l'heure où les compétiteurs et les états
puissances ne cachent plus leurs
ambitions
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Jean-Noël Guérini pour le Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues permettez-moi tout
d'abord de dresser un constat qui sonne
comme un regret mais c'est le ministre
il a fallu attendre le retour de la
guerre sur le sol européen aux portes de
l'Union pour réaliser et surtout assumer
officiellement que l'outil de défense
dont nous disposons est un minima adapté
aux seuls temps de paix
pourtant déjà avant l'évasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie nous avons connu
des sérieux alertes en 2021 deux
exercices interarmiques de simulation de
conflits internationaux
organisé avec les Américains des
Britanniques avaient permis de constater
les limites capacités des forces
françaises la commission de la Défense
nationale des forces armées avait alors
appelé en février 2002 je la cite en une
quinzaine de minutes un premier combat
de frégate avait été envoyé par le fond
et deux autres étaient neutralisés et
elle poursuit
si nous est appellions les pertes au
regard de certains conflits et aériens
il est manifeste que l'aviation de
chasse française pourrait être réduite à
néant en séjour
à qui la faute
avons le à tout le monde et à personne à
la fois ne voyez pas en cette formule
une manière d'excuser une responsabilité
à la noyant dans une
impéristique collective nous avons tous
autant que nous sommes péchés par
naïveté persuadé que la construction
européenne
suffirait à nous préserver merci par
cette douce illusion de paix la nation a
laissé fidèle budget de la défense le
réduisant en variable d'ajustements
pourtant selon les derniers classements
publiés en mai dernier la France dispose
de la neuvième armée au monde et la
première dans l'Union quel paradoxe
après et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre une LPM
2019-2024 à hauteur de 295 milliards qui
entendaient combler les retards dans
tous les domaines des équipements
passants par la préparation
opérationnelle le renseignement ou
encore la condition de la vie militaire
le temps des vaches mères semble révolu
néanmoins si nous nous accordons tous à
dire que l'enveloppe de 413 milliards
d'euros à partir de 2024 sur 7 ans et
substantiel des incertitudes demeure sur
sa soutenabilité comme la rappeler notre
président de la Commission
ainsi l'étalement des cibles de matériel
et la question de l'inflation dans le
coude serait d'ores et déjà estimé à 30
milliards d'euros incitent à la prudence
mais félicitons-nous d'avoir un
commission réorganisée la variation des
crédits dans le temps sans pour autant
modifier le budget global il
progresseront de façon rythmée régulière
de 47 milliards d'euros en 2024 pour
atteindre 69 milliards en 2030 avec ce
montant prêché atteint la nation de
pouvoir garantir la crédibilité dans la
durée de notre dissuasion nucléaire
transformée nos armées aux fins de
conforter notre supériorité
opérationnelle renforcer la cohérence la
préparation et la réactivité de nos
forces armées poursuivre l'attractivité
la fidélisation des militaires et des
civils je ne vais pas détailler les
différentes enveloppes ni les nombreuses
disposition qu'elle soit relatives aux
OPEX avec la mise en place de la
solidarité interministérielle ou les
garde-fous entourant le service national
universel mais je me félicite co-delà de
la prévision de 136 milliards d'euros
pour la préparation de l'emploi des
forces l'entretien programmé du matériel
et des soutien les services de
renseignement du premier cercle
bénéficieront de 5,4 milliards d'euros
de même que 15 milliards d'euros seront
sont consacrés uniquement à l'innovation
et
et à la tronisation des forces nos
forces armées quant à elle bénéficieront
de cycles de matériel dont nous
pourrions élevés l'influence au rang de
fonctions stratégiques l'effort est
notable pour la Marine nationale avec
les commandes de cette patrouilleur de
haute mer et 3 ensembles de chasseurs
remises et la perspective d'un
porte-avion de nouvelles génération à
l'horizon 2037 de même pour l'armée de
l'air avec 137 rafales d'ici 2030
j'espère que les engagements seront
tenus sur les dates et la chair de six
systèmes de Rhodon tout comme l'armée de
terre qui renforce de 2 milliards son
budget munition il est apparu nécessaire
de créer un régime d'apprentissage
militaire et de promouvoir le lien
nation armée pour atteindre des
objectifs quant à la cible de réserve
fixée au plus tard en 2035 et c'est
aussi dans le cas de la promotion de
lien de devient fort nation armée que la
Commission a créé un livret d'épargne
souveraineté destinée aux financement de
l'industrie de défense en complément de
l'effort budgétaires en conclusion en
tant que représentant de la nation nous
nous félicitons des dispositions qui
permettront de sacraliser le rôle du
Parlement à cet égard la Commission a
renforcer la garanties de
l'actualisation dans les temps et par un
vote quoi de plus logique la LPM n'est
pas seulement un test égrenant une
farandole de chiffres dont
l'accumulation peut rendre perplexe le
commun des mortels elle appelle des
ajustements des évolutions qui ne
peuvent être l'otage d'orientation
budgétaire il appartient à la
représentation nationale de veiller au
respect des engagements pris pour la
défense ensemble mes chers collègues
nous devons la construire la consolider
et donc la défendre monsieur le ministre
c'est donc avec bienveillance que le
groupe RDSE abordera l'examen de ce test
je remercie merci chers collègues
et je donne la parole à Monsieur Cédric
Perrin pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues le 24 février 2022 l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie à brutalement
refermé la parenthèse géopolitique
ouverte il y a 30 ans avec la chute de
l'URSS et la fin de la guerre froide
balayant les dernières illusions
héritées de cette période de confort
stratégique l'agression de Moscou a
forcé les Européens à sortir de l'indolé
en face la nouvelle ère dans laquelle
ils sont entrés une ère placée sous le
signe de l'incertitude de la
polarisation et de la confrontation une
ère où les mouvements tectoniques de
l'ordre international qui agissait
jusqu'à présent aba-brui apparaissent
désormais en pleine lumière
réveil des impérialismes affirmation des
puissances régionales
multilatéralisme en délitement recourt
au fait accompli et à la force
diversification des menaces contestation
de l'influence occidentale la guerre en
Ukraine fait partie de ces événements
historiques qui éclaire la bascule du
monde autant qu'il accélère
face à ce séisme géopolitique dont nous
avons encore ce week-end ressenti une
réplique la sécurité de notre continent
et de notre pays n'apparaît plus comme
une évidence mais comme un bien à
protéger cette réalité nous amène
aujourd'hui à examiner ce projet de loi
de programmation militaire
pour la France comme d'ailleurs pour les
autres États d'Europe le constat est
implacable après 30 ans de
désinvestissement massif dans leur
routine de défense c'est largement
démuni pour ne pas dire désarmées qu'ils
abordent le nouveau paradigme
stratégique qui s'impose à eux
depuis plus d'un an tous ou presque ont
affirmé leur volonté de renforcer leur
budget militaire
avec 400 milliards plus 13,3 milliards
d'euros programmés pour les 7 prochaines
années la France s'inscrit pleinement
dans ce mouvement global de
réinvestissement nous vous donnons acte
monsieur le ministre et vous vous êtes
battus pour ça l'enveloppe est
conséquente et ce d'autant qu'elle
intervient à la suite de réels efforts
financiers entre prix depuis 2019 pour
restaurer le potentiel militaire de
notre pays pour autant sera-t-elle
suffisante pour permettre à nos armées
de se hisser rapidement au niveau des
enjeux et des défis posés par la guerre
à l'est de l'Europe sans doute pas et
c'est bien là le grand paradoxe de la
LPM que vous nous proposez aujourd'hui
un paradoxe entre des crédits qui
augmentent fortement et des dotations en
équipements majeurs qui ne progressent
pas pour certains programmes la
situation va même se dégrader puisque
les cibles fixées hier pour 2030 ne
seront finalement atteintes qu'à
l'horizon 2035
nous devons cette vérité aux Français
qui financeront l'effort de défense de
la nation ce n'est pas tant une affaire
de nombre de véhicules parqués dans les
hangars monsieur le ministre que de
remplacement de nos matériels consommés
ou envoyés à nos alliés il n'y aura pas
d'avantage d'hommes et de femmes sous
les drapeaux le format des armées
restera lui aussi
identique à celui qui est visé à la
programmation militaire en cours pour
compenser cette atonie le gouvernement
table sur une augmentation spectaculaire
des effectifs de la réserve
opérationnelle qui serait doublée en 7
ans et nous souscrivons bien entendu à
cet objectif mais suivant en cela
l'analyse du Conseil d'État il me semble
bien difficile de ne pas être sceptique
quant à sa réalisation et pour cause la
lecture de la LPM ne nous permet pas de
comprendre comment le gouvernement
entend financé cette montée en puissance
ni comment il compte former équipé et
employer les réservistes supplémentaires
naturellement ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire préserve à
horizon 2030 des acquis fondamentaux
auxquels nous adhérons en particulier
notre modèle d'armée complet
restera complet évidemment et capable
d'agir dans quasiment tous les domaines
il demeurera sous tendu par une
dissuasion nucléaire indépendante
renouvelée et moderniser malgré là
encore nous devons tenir un langage de
vérité
malgré leur qualité unanimement reconnue
malgré les efforts portés sur leur
cohérence nos armées resteront y compris
au sein d'une coalition
sous-dimensionnée pour faire face à
l'exigence d'un engagement majeur
nécessairement long et coûteux en vie et
en matériel
bien sûr nous comprenons qu'il ne soit
pas possible d'effacer en quelques
années des décennies de désarmement nous
comprenons que tout ne puisse pas être
financé à force servir dans un dans une
période où l'inflation fait peser des
incertitudes budgétaires inédites
permettez-moi à ce titre de souligner à
quel point l'estimation retenue par le
gouvernement environ 30 milliards
d'euros sur la période me semble
optimiste les coûts des grands
équipements militaires n'évoluent pas de
la même manière que le panier de la
ménagère c'est près du double soit Obama
l'équivalent d'une année de
programmation qui pourrait au final être
effacé par l'érosion monétaire
nous comprenons enfin qu'une LPM soit
contrainte de faire des choix mais
précisément ce que nous ne comprenons
moins c'est l'absence de choix
stratégiques forts sur l'orientation de
notre modèle d’armée sur les segments à
privilégier face aux menaces les plus
prégnantes le texte qui nous est soumis
donne davantage l'impression de proroger
l'existant jusqu'à la prochaine élection
présidentielle que de prendre acte des
immenses bouleversements stratégiques
advenues ces derniers mois
c'est me semble-t-il l'une des grandes
occasions manquées de la LPM ce que nous
comprenons moins ensuite c'est le choix
d'affecter au financement de nos armées
certaines ressources frappées d'une si
grande incertitude monsieur le ministre
la fable de la vente des fréquences
tertines est encore dans toutes les
mémoires vous comprendrez donc qu'après
avoir pris connaissance de la vie du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques le
Parlement fasse preuve d'une certaine
méfiance sur le sujet
nous vous proposerons donc sans alourdir
la dette et en respectant le budget
défini par le Président de la République
de sanctuariser véritablement ses 413,3
milliards d'euros et rien que ces 413,3
milliards d'euros sur lesquels vous avez
tant communiqué ce que nous comprenons
moins enfin c'est le choix de précipiter
l'élaboration d'une nouvelle LPM tout en
conservant pour les premières années des
efforts budgétaires identiques à ceux
qui avaient été décidés
en Ukraine c'est-à-dire 3 milliards
d'euros par an car le texte qui nous est
soumis en somme laisse au prochain
Président de la République le soin
d'accélérer la cadence alors que c'est
maintenant que la guerre fait rage en
Europe maintenant que nos armées doivent
remonter en puissance maintenant que
nous industriels ont besoin de
visibilité et donc de commandes pour
donner un temps soit peu corps à la
notion d'économie de guerre si cher au
président de la République
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous entrerons dans la discussion de ce
texte avant tout animée d'un esprit de
responsabilité tant vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens que vis-à-vis de nos soldats
de nos marins et de nous aviateurs qui
acceptent de faire de leur vie notre
ultime rempart face aux menaces nous
n'avons donc pas l'intention d'ajouter
des milliards au milliards nous sommes
trop conscients de la situation
financière déplorable de notre pays pour
nous permettre une quelconque
désinvolture en la matière notre
commission conduite par notre excellent
président et rapporteur Christian Cambon
défendra néanmoins quelques idées
simples d'une part ne pas laisser
subsister le moindre doute sur le fait
que les ressources les ressources
promises à nos armées seront bel et bien
au rendez-vous d'autre part veillez à ce
que le rythme auquel elles seront mises
à leur disposition soient crédibles et
surtout compatible avec l'évolution des
dangers qui pèse sur la France et
l'Europe
je ne sais pas si une courbe budgétaire
permet de protéger notre nation monsieur
le ministre mais devant les menaces nous
ne croyons pas à la stratégie d'une
défense en pente douce car en définitive
cette courbe définit tout le reste a
commencé par la crédibilité la sincérité
et l'efficacité de la programmation à
venir je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent je vais le dire
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
Républiques et territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
seul pays de l'Union à disposé d'un
modèle d'armée complet la France est
engagée depuis de nombreuses années dans
la lutte contre les groupes terroristes
que ce soit en Afrique le vent ou en
Asie central jusqu'au cas de nos
partenaires ne connaissons le prix de la
souveraineté et celui du sang je veux
rendre hommage à toutes celles et ceux
qui ont donné de leur vie pour la France
à ceux qui ont été blessés ainsi qu'à
l'ensemble de nos forces leur engagement
et leur professionnalisme nous
permettent d'être libre la guerre est de
retour sur notre continent autant que
nous le pouvons nous devons continuer à
de soutenir l'Ukraine qui se bat pour
survivre pour l'Europe et pour la
liberté ce soutien ne doit cependant pas
opérer la montée en puissance de nos
capacités
la Commission sur la conduite notre
président a veillé à maintenir ce chemin
de crête il était trois mais il est
incontournable jusqu'en 2030 les besoins
de nos armées s'élèvent à plus de 400
milliards d'euros la Commission a fait
le choix de lycée davantage
l'augmentation du budget de la défense
afin de crédibiliser cette hausse un
fonds européen destiné à l'industrie de
la recherche dans le domaine militaire a
vu le jour d'un montant de 7 milliards
d'euros pour la période 2021 2027 se
font européen démontre la prise de
conscience unanime de la nécessité
d'agir solidairement pour les défenses
de notre continent nous devons pouvoir
faire face au réarmement qui est non
seulement français mais aussi européen
et international
nous autres prises doivent être à la
hauteur de ces enjeux et prête à
répondre à la demande dans mon
département ça va des petites
entreprises comme par exemple EM2 à
Ancenis une très des très rare en
entreprise spécialisées dans les
emballages d'obus qui fait face
actuellement à une demande exponentielle
en raison de la guerre en Ukraine c'est
un chiffre absolument faramineux qui est
la demande qui leur a été faite ce qui
montre la gravité de la situation aux
grandes entreprises comme naval Group et
les chantiers d'Atlantique qui seront
chargés de construire d'ici 2038 un
porte-avions à Saint-Nazaire pour un
budget supérieur à 5 milliards d'euros à
ce sujet j'attire votre attention
monsieur le ministre un véritable défi
doit être relevé une part significative
des travaux à Saint-Nazaire est réalisé
par des sous-traitants étrangers pour un
cours salarial moins élevé ce qui bien
sûr nous interpelle nous devons d'ores
et déjà former du personnel qualifié
capable d'assumer la construction de
futurs
doit être au rendez-vous sur le plan
éducatif sur le plan de la formation
professionnelle mais également pour
accompagner les petites et les moyennes
entreprises qui devront investir pour
absorber une demande croissante la
visibilité pour les programmes à venir
est essentiel pour ces entreprises si
nous voulons des acteurs français
capables de répondre à des besoins
complexes et variés en matière de
défense leur contribution à la sécurité
nationale européenne et internationale
est inestimable notre engagement
d'indéfense et la sécurité est non
seulement un impératif stratégique mais
c'est aussi une opportunité de renforcer
notre industrie de créer des emplois et
de stimuler l'innovation nos entreprises
sont un atout pour l'économie de nos
territoires elle constitue une source
d'expertise technologique de premier
plan mais également de développement qui
contribue non seulement à notre sécurité
mais aussi à notre prospérité la
dissuasion nucléaire doit rester de la
clé de voûte de notre stratégie de
défense il nous faut absolument
préserver cet héritage général de Gaulle
qui a permis à la France d'être libre
pour demeurer crédible nous devons
veiller à l'entretien au développement
de nos vecteurs ceci présente bien sûr
un coût il est très élevé mais c'est
aussi celui de notre liberté il est donc
pas négociable nos forces
conventionnelles doivent également être
préparées à être engagés dans des
conflits de haute intensité
contrairement à Poutine nous ne voulions
pas nous ne voulons pas que nous soit
que nous soldats ne soient que de la
chair à canon ce n'est pas notre
conception nous les considérons comme
les techniciens très efficaces qui
doivent pouvoir servir en bénéficiant du
meilleur matériel la LPM prévoit donc
pour les années à venir une montée en
gamme la France s'apprête à moderniser
ses équipements en privilégiant la
qualité
sur la quantité les dernières
technologies sont certes plus onéreuses
mais elles permettent une précision et
une discrétion qui peut faire la
différence aujourd'hui comme hier la
patrie a besoin de femmes et d'hommes
pour la défendre les effectifs de nos
armées devront être portés à 275 000 TP
en 2030 pour les appuyer mais aussi pour
faire vivre le lien armée nationale LPM
prévoit d'accroître le nombre de
réservistes à 80000 à l'horizon 2030 et
nous approuvons cette orientation afin
de parvenir à nos objectifs nous avons
également besoin de renforcer notre base
industrielle et technologique de défense
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le texte
simplifie la passation de marché et
adapte les enquêtes de coûts plusieurs
dispositions également pour objet de
permettre à la France de disposer de
matériel nécessaire à une confrontation
la création d'un livret d'épargne
souveraineté est à cette vie regardes
pertinente
mes chers collègues l'invasion l'Ukraine
par la Russie marque le début d'une
nouvelle ère d'autres conflits de haute
intensité pourraient éclater à l'avenir
impliquant la France ou ses alliés la
guerre est toujours un tragédie il est
de notre devoir de préparer au mieux
notre pays à cette triste éventualité
Clémenceau disait qu'il faut savoir ce
que l'on veut quand on le sait il faut
avoir le courage de le dire et quand le
dit il faut avoir le courage de le faire
nous avons dit ce que nous voulons à
nous d'avoir le courage de le faire
merci mes chers collègues merci chers
collègues la parole est ensuite au
président Guillaume gonta pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission je voulais d'abord
souligner l'engagement des femmes et des
hommes au sein de notre armée et souvent
au péril de leur vie nous examinons
cette loi de programmation militaire
dans le contexte que chacun connaît et
après le nouveau robotissement de ce
week-end permettez-moi en préambule de
rappeler notre plein et entier soutien
au peuple ukrainien et à ses dirigeants
dans la reconquête de leur souveraineté
l'invasion russe en Ukraine a justifié
aux yeux du gouvernement la nécessité
d'accélérer le processus d'élaboration
et d'adoption de la présente loi de
programmation militaire
les termes économie de guerre se sont
même invités activement dans le propos
présidentiel monsieur le ministre malgré
vos explications répétées nous ne
comprenons pas l'urgence qui guide le
gouvernement nous ne voyons pas de
rupture telle avec les deux dernières
LPM que justifierait pourtant la
nouvelle donne géostratégique européenne
et mondiale nous voyons une LPM dans la
continuité des deux précédentes mais
élaboré avec un déficit de concertation
parlementaire et démocratique cela est
dommageable car vous demandez un effort
important à la nation avec une
augmentation du budget des armées de
près de 50% d'ici à 2030 et un effort
global de plus de 118 milliards d'euros
sur le reste de la décennie 17 milliards
par an en moyenne sans financement
spécifique vous étiez plus regardant
pour trouver 13 milliards pour nos
caisses de retraite quitte à mettre le
pays dans un état d'extrême tension et
piétiner la démocratie parlementaire
votre gouvernement enfermé dans son
dogmatisme refuse de faire contribuer
les plus aisés à l'effort national et
promet un retour du déficit public sous
les 3% d'ici la fin du quinquennat
comment dans ces conditions allez-vous
financer cette lettre et cette lprpm vos
prévisions de croissance sont un leur ce
débat nécessite que nous connaissions
les perdants ça ne sera pas l'intérieur
et la justice désormais doté de leur
propre programmation budgétaire alors
qui la transition écologique l'éducation
nationale la culture aucun et aucune de
ces solutions n'est acceptable et c'est
pour nous une ligne rouge si nous
comprenons l'effort de rattrapage
budgétaire du ministère si nous avons
bien en tête que cette crédit
correspondent souvent au paiement de
programme déjà engagés si nous
n'ignorons pas l'explosion du coût des
matériels qui induit le saut
technologique et les nouveaux espaces de
conflictualité il n'en reste pas moins
que vous demandez beaucoup d'argent et
que vous n'avez pas défini l'urgence de
la menace et le besoin pour la France
d'y faire face seul ou presque à vous
entendre et c'est aussi une faiblesse de
cette LPM on a parfois le sentiment que
la France est seule seul au monde
qu'elle doit être en capacité de faire
face à une guerre de haute intensité sur
son sol et sans aide de ses voisins or
ce que or ce que ce nouveau contexte
géostratégique nous rappelle c'est
l'immense dépendance des Européens aux
États-Unis pour assurer la sécurité de
notre continent malgré cette froide
réalité la France et ce projet en est
l'illustration cultive son rêve
d'autonomie et de puissance d'équilibre
nous ne partageons pas ce récit la
France est une puissance bien plus
moyenne qu'elle veut le croire et
continuer à promouvoir un modèle d'armée
complète c'est prendre le risque du
saupoudrage de l'échantillonnage et
cette LPM n'échappe pas à ce constat
chacun conviendra résultat des courses
pour renouveler la dissuasion nucléaire
au coût exorbitant pour dégager des
marges pour investir de nouveaux espaces
de conflictualité
nous investissons pas comme nous le
devrions pour notre armée de terre pour
son équipement et pour le confort de vie
des soldats et de leur famille cette
fameuse armée à hauteur d'homme chère à
votre prédécesseur les écologistes pour
leur part considèrent que notre effort
ne peut être coréen nos besoins en homme
en équipement en stock stratégique en
munitions ne peuvent se mesurer que dans
le cadre d'une coalition européenne la
revue nationale stratégique était d'une
grande faiblesse en la matière et le
rapport annexé de la présente LPM
améliorée par l'Assemblée nationale et
le Sénat demeure insuffisant quelle
coordination de notre effort avec ceux
de nos voisins et notamment avec
l'effort sans précédent opérer
outre-reins quelle impulsion pour une
base industrielle et technologique de
défense résolument européenne une
nécessité tant pour harmoniser nos
équipements que pour diminuer nos coûts
de production quel nouveau effort pour
construire politiquement la réponse
européenne au défi stratégique du 21e
siècle
pour conclure sur le renforcement des
efforts de transition écologique et
énergétique de l'armée qui reste à ce
stade largement incantatoire je pense en
premier chef à la rénovation du bâti
bien sûr la solution nos armées est à
part mais en tant que premier poste
ministériel en termes de consommation
d'énergie fossile un effort temps
écologique financier doit être produit
avec les six petites minutes qui
mettaient un parti ce propos est
davantage un préambule qu'un tableau
général et je profiterai bien évidemment
des jours de débats qui s'ouvrent pour
être plus complet merci merci cher
président et à présent la parole est à
Nicole Duranton pour le groupe
rassemblement
démocrate progressiste et indépendant
merci monsieur le président
avant d'entrer dans le vif de ce texte
fondateur qui marquera notre politique
de défense pour les prochaines années
j'aimerais m'adresser directement à nos
soldats vous êtes des femmes et des
hommes d'exception engagés en France et
aux quatre coins du monde votre
combativité est inégalable votre
amnégation est un modèle pour tous je
veux dire au nom de notre groupe RDPI
combien nous sommes fiers de nos
militaires combien nous vous en sommes
reconnaissants
je crois qu'au fond dans cette hémicycle
nous défendons un objectif commun celui
de protéger notre population et notre
souveraineté et celui d’accorder à nos
armées les moyens d'atteindre cet
objectif
nous visions des choses et nous manières
d'y arriver sont multiples mais jusqu'à
présent nous avons toujours su avancer
ensemble je forme le vœu que les débats
de ces prochains jours se déroulent
sereinement et qu'il soit constructif
j'espère que nous discutions nous
permettrons d'y voir plus clair en
particulier quant au moyen budgétaire de
cette programmation militaire
c'est finalement il y a lieu d'augmenter
l'enveloppe budgétaire nous en
débattrons elle prévoit en effet des
moyens financiers progressifs et
suffisamment conséquent pour permettre à
notre armée de rattraper le retard
d'investissement pris depuis 30 ans
sans pour autant déséquilibrer le budget
de la nation ou venir impacter d'autres
postes de dépenses qui sont nécessaires
aux Français si en revanche il y a lieu
de maintenir la même enveloppe globale
ce débat sera l'occasion de comprendre
où les coupes budgétaires doivent se
faire pour compenser les nouvelles
dépenses intégrées
en ce qui concerne notre groupe nous
faisons le choix de faire confiance en
notre état-major et notre ministre des
armées est un major avec qui cette loi
de programmation militaire a été
minutieusement pensé et élaborer
nous faisons également le choix de ne
pas rigidifier le travail de
l'état-major de lui laisser l'attitude
nécessaire pour s'adapter à tous les
défis
au cours de ces prochains jours notre
groupe vous proposera plusieurs
amendements sur des sujets qui nous
tiennent à cœur par exemple pour
compléter les missions de l'Office
national des anciens combattants et des
victimes de guerre
launager afin de le conforter dans son
rôle de relais territorial de l'action
memoriale du ministère j'en profite pour
saluer le travail incessant de madame la
ministre en charge des anciens
combattants et de la mémoire pleinement
engagés aux côtés des anciens
combattants et des blessés de guerre par
exemple avec le remarquable plan blessé
2023 2027 présentée le 10 mai dernier
ou encore un amendement pour stopper une
inégalité de traitement entre étudiants
en supprimant le paiement de droit
d'inscription des élèves des lycées de
défense qui viendraient à être exonéré
de droits d'inscription sur des critères
sociaux
dès 2017 le président de la République a
engagé une politique de rupture avec ses
prédécesseurs afin de mettre un terme à
plusieurs décennies de diminution de nos
capacités militaires
dans le cadre de cette loi de
programmation militaire pour 2024 2030
il est essentiel que la France continue
de renforcer ses moyens garantir son
autonomie stratégique assurer ses
engagements en tant qu'aliés de l'OTAN
et membre de l'Union européenne être une
puissance d'équilibre
avec cette nouvelle LPM on passe une
première loi de réparation
2019-2025 à une loi de transformation de
nos capacités de défense pour être plus
efficace et performant
outre le renouvellement des capacités
opérationnelles le ministère des armées
a entrepris un effort de modernisation
cette modernisation participe de la
réforme de l'État et vise notamment à
dégager des marges de manœuvre
budgétaire pour adopter les capacités
militaires notamment les équipements
garantir les normes d'activité et
d'entraînement et poursuivent
l'amélioration de la condition du
personnel civil et militaire le
ministère des armées travaille avec 10
grands groupes 4000 PME et et 200 000
personnes près de 27000 entreprises sont
partenaires du ministère des armées
mes chers collègues sur ces 413
milliards d'euros qui sont nécessaires
pour garantir notre sécurité
268 milliards vont principalement
profiter à nos industries soutenir
l'emploi dans les territoires préservés
et développer les compétences on sait
que pour un million d'euros
d'investissements on génère cet emploi
direct et indirect
aussi au cours des décennies la France a
fondé sa politique de défense et de
sécurité entre autres sur la dissuasion
du clair et la notion d'autonomie
stratégique élaborée vis-à-vis de l'OTAN
les menaces identifiées dans le Livre
blanc de 2008 se sont amplifiés
terrorisme cybermenas prolifération du
nucléaire pandémie
dans un tel contexte l'objectif d'une
souveraineté maîtrisée concerne les
domaines critiques de la dissuasion
l'accès à l'espace la capacité d'entrée
en premier mais aussi le renseignement
la dégradation du contexte
géostratégique à entraîner l'émergence
d'une idée d'autonomie stratégique
européenne et doit conduire à prendre en
compte le retour de la notion de guerre
à haute intensité comme en Ukraine
en effet cette guerre a rappelé la
nécessité de disposer de solides système
de défense antiméciles et anti-aérien en
cas de conflit avec une puissance
étrangère 5 milliards son programme est
dans le rapport annexé sur la période
pour la défense surface r le cyber 4
milliards les drones et robots 5
milliards les stocks de munitions 16
milliards la fabrication d'un
porte-avions nouvelle génération 10
milliards ces éléments figurent parmi
les priorités stratégiques de
développement pour les armées françaises
cette programmation militaire ne se
résume pas au sols investissements
matériels elle comprend aussi un volet
humain très important avec un doublement
de la réserve opérationnelle et plus de
6400 créations de poste avec 700
nouveaux postes ouverts dès 2024 et 2025
un objectif qui s'il est réalisé
dépasseraient les augmentations de
postes réalisés par la précédente LPM
selon les chiffres de la Cour des
comptes
cette programmation militaire comprend
aussi un plan famille de 750 millions
d'euros pour compenser les absences et
les contraintes opérationnelles et une
politique RH modernisée avec une gestion
des carrières rénovée
dans l'Indo-Pacifique face à une Chine
qui ne cesse de multiplier ses
démonstrations de puissance cette
programmation militaire permet à la
France de tenir son rang grâce à son
armée et grâce à ses territoires
d'outre-mer un effort particulier sera
fait sur les infrastructures en
outre-mer la parooutre-mer de la LPM
sera 13 milliards d'euros sur la période
nos forces de souveraineté bénéficieront
d'un effort généralisé sur le plan
capacitaire Corvette avion de transport
drone génie dual et constitueront un
premier échelon renforcé immédiatement
disponible afin de décourager toute
tentative de stabilise de
déstabilisation ou de prédation
elle disposeront par ailleurs de
capacités de surveillance qui améliorons
la couverture de nos territoires
outre-mer et leurs zones économiques
exclusives les capacités de commandement
seront durcies de manière ciblée en
fonction des enjeux régionaux des
réformes et une noix de programmation
qui envoient le signal clair que la
France peut compter sur une armée
moderne et totalement connectée à son
époque pour atteindre d'ici 2030 un
modèle d'armée complet et équilibré apte
à répondre à l'ensemble des menaces je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
et la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Folliot pour le groupe l'Union centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mes chers collègues
tous ces milliards que nous apprêtons à
voter tous ces moyens tous ces matériels
qui vont entrer dans le cadre de cette
loi de programmation militaire ne serait
rien sans celles et ceux qui les servent
je voudrais rendre un hommage
particulier à nos soldats à nos
aviateurs nos marins à l'ensemble des
personnels des services de renseignement
ceux qui s'occupe de cyber ceux qui
s'occupe aussi de soutien les personnes
civiles les ingénieurs de leur moment en
fait toutes celles et ceux
réserventissent compris qui contribuent
à cet effort de défense
c'est un élément particulièrement
important et essentiel monsieur le
ministre c'est la cinquième loi de
programmation militaire à laquelle
j'assiste dans le cadre des débats
parlementaires c'est certainement la
première est un élément important au
travers de cette augmentation de budget
je dirais il faut rendre à César ce qui
est à ses arbres plutôt à Macron ce qui
est à Macron c'est à dire au président
de la République cette volonté donc de
doubler le budget de notre défense et
c'est un élément important et un élément
essentiel et fondamental je voudrais
dans ce cadre-là dire combien il est
important aussi de ne pas rester
focalisé sur des enjeux d'actualité ce
qui se passe en Europe de l'Est et est
un élément important essentiel et nous
devons continuer à appuyer à soutenir
nos amis Ukrainiens dans leur combat
pour les valeurs pour la liberté pour
leur souveraineté pour leur indépendance
mais au-delà de des éléments il y a un
certain nombre d'enjeux qui sont des
enjeux particulièrement particulièrement
importants je voudrais en citer
quelques-uns monsieur le ministre cette
loi de programmation militaire
malheureusement pour moi à certains
égards elle manquent d'audace si vous me
permettez l'expression nous sommes
encore dans ce qu'on pourrait ce que je
me permettrais de qualifier de Global
rikiki c'est-à-dire donc une posture
globale nous avons tout de la dissuasion
jusqu'au fantassins sur le terrain mais
nous avons tout en très petit et il est
dommage de ne pas avoir eu cette
capacité à pouvoir prioriser un certain
nombre de choses j'en citerai d'eux
d'une part la capacité de projection
parce que ce qui fait la force de nos
forces de nos armées c'est cette
capacité à pouvoir entrer en théâtre et
puis le deuxième point ce sont les
forces de souveraineté les forces de
souveraineté c'est quelque chose
d'important 15000 effectifs il y a 30
ans
8700 il y a
moins de 7000 aujourd'hui et c'est un
enjeu un enjeu important et majeur parce
que au delà du fait comme vous l'avez
dit de la nécessité de tenir compte des
enjeux régionaux derrière cela se joue
quelque chose qui est encore plus
essentiel c'est la capacité de notre
pays à donner de la crédibilité à sa
stratégie
Indo-Pacifique alors certes nous sommes
aussi protégés par l'article 5 de l'OTAN
et nous sommes dans un système
d'alliance je regrette du reste que
l'article 42-7 de l'Union européenne ne
revêt pas peut-être une importance plus
importante pour nombre d'autres acteurs
mais il faut poursuivre les efforts de
réarmement en vue de nos forces de
souveraineté il faut monsieur le
ministre sortir de cette logique qui
fait que sur les 26 bases aériennes
aucune de plein exercices aucune dans
les outre-mer il faut sortir de la
logique des deux moitiés Brest Toulon
pour aller pour notre marine nationale
vers une logique des quatre-quarts Brest
Toulon
Saint-Denis de la Réunion Nouméa ou
Papeete pour le Pacifique il faut sortir
de cette logique d'avoir uniquement des
régiments tournants pour l'armée de
terre avoir des régiments
prépositionnels pour avoir une capacité
de projection à partir des Outre-mer ce
sont tous ces enjeux qu'il faut relever
et je crois qu'il y a par rapport par
rapport à tout cela un objectif une
ambition collective que nous devons
avoir nous défendrons un certain nombre
d'amendements pour permettre ceci pour
essayer de faire de telle sorte qu'il
puisse y avoir cette lisibilité cette
stratégie qui fasse que la France
finalement
ne soit ne se conseiller des repas tels
que elle croit être c'est à dire
continental européenne mais elle agisse
en fonction de ce qu'est elle est aussi
au delà du fait d'être continental
européenne c'est d'être mondial et
maritime je vous remercie
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Pascal Lisa pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président est
rapporteur chers collègues la défense
c'est la première raison d'être de
l'État il n'y peut manquer sans se
détruire lui-même telle était la
conception du général de Gaulle la loi
de programmation militaire est donc
déterminante pour notre avenir dans le
contexte actuel et en effet depuis la
dernière le monde connaît un regain de
tension inquiétant l'Europe est
confrontée à un conflit majeur causé par
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
Russie puissance de thé membre permanent
du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU de
l'OSCE ceci en dit long sur l'état de
l'ordre international nous redécouvrons
à nos dépens que la paix ne va pas de
soi combien de programmes militaires est
allé de coupe budgétaire et de réduction
d'effectifs ont été justifiées en Europe
par les dividendes de la la France n'a
pas échappé à cette tendance même si
elle a su conserver avec peine un modèle
complet d'armée et une BITD performante
mais aujourd'hui un nouvel ordre mondial
se met en place entre le camp
occidental le reste du monde et le pôle
Russo chinois l'Europe pourrait se
trouver cornérisée une Russie au pouvoir
contestée par des mercenaires
nationalistes cernés par l'OTAN et
dépendante de la Chine est en fait une
menace sérieuse pour la sécurité rien ne
me paraît plus dangereux qu'un pays
acculé au seuil de la guerre civile
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'une puissance
nucléaire aux multiples capacités
militaires ces évolutions ne sont pas
sans conséquence sur nos intérêts et en
Afrique la pression des compétiteurs
stratégiques s'approi y compris sur
l'espace franc
leur stratégie de soft power s'y déploie
en même temps que d'autres moyens
hybrides ce sont là les outils du jeu
des puissances auxquelles nous devons
être préparés l'opération barkhane a
montré le savoir-faire de nos armées
mais aussi les limites du pôle du modèle
expéditionnaire français grâce à leur
capacité d'adaptation nos forces sont
obtenues des succès incontestables au
prix néanmoins d'une usure des
personnels des matériels mais aussi de
pertes humaines notables en
indopacifique nos forces sont présentes
en particulier la marine et agissent
avec nos alliés de la région face
notamment à la Chine qui avance ces
pions à marche forcée et avec habileté
autour de nos outre-mer l'immensité des
zones souveraineté française à
surveiller à protéger restera un défi
les drones et le traitement de masse des
données par intelligence artificielle ne
pourront pas tout
être et durée telle est la problématique
posée au chef militaire quand sera-t-il
demain dans la perspective d'un conflit
complexe de haute intensité mêlant tous
les champs de la conflictualité et
entraînant une forte attrition des
moyens
un rétexte rapide de l'exercice Orion 23
permettra de savoir où la France en est
dans ce domaine et d'envisager des
ajustements quand sera-t-il dans la
perspective de conflit larvé mais plus
hybride l'action combinée de quelques
centaines de mercenaires Wagner sur le
terrain africain et d'opérations de
propagande désinformation a permis de
prendre le contrôle de fait de certains
états conduisant à l'éviction de la
mission barkham les cybersattaques
contre nos hôpitaux font aussi des
dégâts dangereux et coûteux prenons-nous
pleinement la mesure de la force de ces
déstabilisation réalisée à moindre coût
je n'en suis pas convaincu
pour préserver la paix les capacités
actuelles ne sont plus suffisantes il
faut des moyens adaptés dimensionnés
capables d'évoluer rapidement vous
portez monsieur le ministre cette LPM
avec des ambitions fortes des moyens
forts annoncés et aussi une certaine
communication le Sénat examine ce texte
avec sérieux voulu par le président
Cambon les différents groupes de travail
ont conduit des dizaines d'auditions sur
plusieurs mois c'est mon cas avec mes
collègues des groupes sur le
renseignement et la prospective et sur
le bilan de l'opération par Cannes les
amendements adoptés en commission
témoignent d'une volonté d'aider les
armées sans esprit de polémique il est
souhaitable que leur contenu demeure
dans le texte final
je ne m'étendrai pas sur le montage
financier de cet LPM nous faisons vous
faites des hypothèses notamment sur
l'inflation vous tablez nous tablons sur
des ressources additionnelles certaines
plus incertaines que d'autres si je puis
dire ainsi que sur des ajustements de
dépenses au fil de l'eau avec le poids
de la dette néanmoins les mauvaises
surprises sont sans doute à venir
la défense se sont aussi des industries
que seraient nos forces dans une béité
des fortes et indépendante la
concurrence d'entreprises étrangères aux
contraintes limitées et fortement
soutenu par leurs états se durcit les
financements sont cruciaux pour la
survie d'un des derniers écosystèmes
industriels français il s'agit d'une
filière d'excellence non délocalisables
qui représentent un vivier d'emplois
dans les territoires malgré les efforts
de l'État trop d'entreprises sont
passées ces dernières années sous
pavillon étrangers notamment pour y
trouver les financements nécessaires à
leur croissance
d'autres craignent de devoir être
absorbés par de grands groupes d'y
perdre leur liberté et leur capacité à
innover quant aux grands groupes ils
redoutent eux la défaillance d'un de
leurs fournisseurs critiques
les soutiens publics sont importants les
financements privés le sont tout autant
il faut créer un environnement favorable
pour les banques et les investisseurs le
passage à une économie de guerre ne
pourra pas se faire sans eux par
ailleurs un plus grand activisme
français s'impose sur les projets de
textes européens qui impacteront
l'industrie défense la veille ne suffit
plus car derrière ces textes à vocation
écologiques et sociales il y a souvent
des lobbys qui poursuivent en fait début
politique et économique contraire à nos
intérêts n’ajoutons pas des contraintes
inappropriées qu'il faut se ainsi encore
un peu plus la concurrence aussi j'ai
fait adopter en commission de nombreux
amendements pour conforter notre BITD la
pérennité de ces industries requiert une
visibilité de commande elle leur permet
de pouvoir réaliser les investissements
souvent lourds les stocks les machines
outils les robots de maintenir les
compétences et de pouvoir embaucher pour
répondre aux besoins des armées en
particulier dans le contexte d'économie
de guerre les stops and go empêcheront
de produire vite et mieux la continuité
industrielle est indispensable car les
capacités et les compétences se perdent
vite mais se rattrape lentement
le paradigme des coopérations
européennes atteint aussi ses limites
avec nos partenaires allemands rien est
simple ni sur le Scaff ni sur le mgcs il
y a aussi beaucoup de vigilance à voir
sur ces points alors Monsieur le
Ministre avec la guerre en Ukraine les
autorités russes sont partis du postulat
selon lequel les démocraties sont
faibles sont malades elles ont
d'ailleurs tout fait pour les diviser et
mieux les affaiblir face aux instincts
belliqueux portés par la convergence des
autoritarismes nous devons nous les
démocraties afficher une détermination
sans faille le droit et les valeurs sont
des instruments nécessaires mais
insuffisants pour défendre nos sociétés
démocratiques
donnons-nous ensemble réellement les
moyens à la hauteur de nos ambitions et
des menaces nouvelles je vous remercie
merci chers
pour les républicains
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'examen de
la loi de programmation militaire par
notre Haute Assemblée constitue toujours
de ces moments graves et solennel où
nous réalisons que ce qui se joue n'est
ni plus ni moins que la sécurité de
notre pays et de nos compatriotes et
donc de leur avenir c'est une lourde
responsabilité qui nous incombe alors
dans ce monde où plus personne ne le
nira désormais les enjeux de sécurité de
défense n'ont jamais été aussi cruciaux
investi au sein de la Commission à faire
étrangères défend ses forces armées du
Sénat depuis mon entrée au Sénat en 2004
j'ai parfois eu l'impression que ces
enjeux de défense et de sécurité
n'avaient pas toujours été prise en
compte alors juste valeur et je me
réjouis donc d'autant plus que la prise
de conscience collective aussi bien dans
l'opinion que par les décideurs publics
de leur importance primordiale
à l'heure où l'Ukraine se bat avec un
courage admirable il est indispensable
d'afficher clairement dans cette LPM
nous ambitions en matière de sécurité
collective et notre ferme volonté de
tenir notre rond en tant que première
année de l'Union européenne et de
maillon essentiels de l'OTAN cette
alliance euro-atlantique qui n'a jamais
failli et qui est la meilleure garante
aujourd'hui de notre sécurité et de
notre défense collective
l'enrichissement substantiel de ce texte
que nous avons proposé en commission
démontre une nouvelle fois la qualité du
travail de notre assemblée et
contribuera très nettement à mettre
cette LPM au niveau que nos armées à qui
je veux rendre ici moi aussi un hommage
appuyé sont en droit d'attendre et à la
mesure des engagements qui sont les
nôtres vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens et
de nos alliés partenaire l'adoption de
cette LPM permettra ainsi à la France au
sommet prochain de l'OTAN les 11 et 12
juillet à Vilnius d'apparaître aussi
crédible et fiable qu'elle se doit de
l'être je rappellerai que les 274
membres de l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OTAN que j'ai l'honneur de présider et
dont je porterai la voix auprès des 31
chefs d'État et de gouvernement lors de
ce sommet de ginus appelle à l'unanimité
à renforcer le soutien politique et
militaire à l'Ukraine et à renforcer
notre politique de défense et de
dissuasion en consacrant plus de moyens
à la croissance de nos capacités
collectives n'ayant que 5 minutes et
arrivant toute fin de discussion et ne
voulant pas répéter tout ce qui a été
dit et excellent non dit par plusieurs
de mes collègues je me contenterai de
m'arrêter sur deux autres sujets tout
d'abord la désinformation la guerre
informationnelle qui est menée
quotidiennement par la Russie notamment
et d'une grande violence et ses
conséquences pourraient être des plus
désastreuses et destructrice pour notre
pays nos sociétés nos démocraties si
nous ne la prenons pas collectivement en
compte mettant moi-même penché sur cette
nouvelle forme de guerre dans un rapport
que j'ai présenté à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN je voudrais
insister sur la nécessité de se préparer
de se former et donc de s'armer et ce
dès le plus jeune âge comme cela se fait
dans plusieurs états scandinaves face à
ses attaques qui visent à saper les
fondements même de nos sociétés
démocratiques
ensuite découlant de ces nouvelles
mesures il me semble tout aussi
essentielles de développer nos outils
d'influence et de renforcer le lien
armée nation et ce tout particulièrement
auprès de nos jeunes Français établis à
l'étranger de plus en plus nombreux les
journées défenses et citoyenneté
représentent à ce titre une excellente
opportunité pour acquérir les premières
connaissances indispensables à la
compréhension des grands enjeux de
défense qui touchent notre pays mais
séjourner ne sont à mon grand regret que
rarement organisé alors même que les
jeunes Français résidents à l'étranger
sont déjà exclus du SNU et je défendrai
des amendements ce sens ne perdons pas
de vue que les Français établis hors de
France demeurent la vitrine de notre
pays à l'international un de nos
meilleurs outils d'influence un relais
essentiel chez nos partenaires alliés et
parfois admis les Français établis hors
de France sont des Français à part
entière des citoyens engagés qui ne
demandent qu'à servir pays que ce soit
par la promotion de nos intérêts
économiques par une vague géostratégique
par une cyber des chances adaptée ou
encore par une lutte contre la
désinformation c'est un devoir et une
responsabilité de les soutenir et donc
de leur donner dans ce texte les moyens
de mieux servir notre pays nos armées et
nos valeurs ne les décevons pas merci de
votre attention
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Belin
dernier orateur de cette discussion
générale
[Applaudissements]
messieurs le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames les ministres monsieur
le Président cher Christian Combault
mesdames messieurs cette loi de
programmation militaire est essentielle
pour plusieurs raisons d'avoir le
contexte géopolitique internationale
nous avons tous en tête la guerre en
Ukraine c'est le fait générateur
mais il y a d'autres événements
évidemment à suivre et première pensée
pour l'Afrique nous avons eu le débat il
y a quelques jours et c'est vrai qu'il y
a une dégradation incontestable de la
situation en Afrique avec le
développement d'un sentiment
anti-français je pense au Mali je pense
centrale malheureusement au Burkina Faso
et puis au Maghreb c'était évoqué la
semaine dernière ici même
par nos outre-mer nous avons une
responsabilité
sur l'ensemble du globe c'est à la fois
un atout mais c'est aussi pour nous
évidemment une obligation et je salue
l'ensemble de mes collègues ultramarins
présents ça veut dire que ça va
nécessiter des moyens maritimes dont
nous reparlerons monsieur le ministre
et puis il y a d'autres théâtres
d'opérations potentielles je pense à
l'Iran l'Afghanistan la Corée du Nord
toute cette accumulation de menaces sur
tous les continents vient obliger
effectivement en moyenne nouveau et
c'est ce qui fait que nécessité
d'actualiser la loi de programmation
militaire
et puis les guerres sont multiples c'est
l'autre grande raison
c'est le grand changement du 21e siècle
il y a les vieilles guerres les guerres
brutales les images que nous voyons en
Ukraine rappelle celle de nos livres
d'histoire sur la Première Guerre
mondiale
une époque où chaque tranchée était un
couloir de la mort
et puis il y a des nouvelles guerres
pernicieuses il y a effectivement cette
garde technologie
où on a une montée en puissance
de l'informatique du numérique du
Cantique aussi vers où les drones sont
partout et demain l'intelligence
artificielle
et puis il y a ces guerres aussi
liées au terroriste tout à l'heure notre
collègue qui intervenait pas mal avait
mis en date comme ça tournant le 11
septembre bien sûr nous avons tous en
tête le 11 septembre 2001
mais chemise je ne pensais parce que
j'espère que vous en ferez la
commémoration dans quelques semaines
pour le Drakkar au Liban octobre 1983 ou
déjà le terrorisme était venu voilà se
mêler à la guerre et l'ensemble de ces
données vient justifier des moyens
nouveaux variés indispensable face
aux menaces et à diversification des
menaces c'est un effort indispensable
face à la confiscuité de demain avec
nécessité de transformer nos armées
de l'aimer d'anticiper et bien
évidemment d'associer la nation parce
que ces risques nouveaux font qu'il y
ait une exposition civile alors une fois
qu'on a posé le cadre évidemment il y a
la question des moyens et des ressources
humaines les moyens monsieur le ministre
ils sont essentiels vous en avez
longuement évoqué tout à l'heure avec
leur apporteurs
en tête la tête de pont la tête de
chapitre c'est évidemment la dissuasion
nucléaire et nous devons la rappeler
nous devons réaffirmer cette dissuasion
nucléaire et puis derrière il y a les
moyens maritimes ou en sommes-nous nos
sous-marins ou en sommes-nous d'un
prochain porte-avions ils nous portons
ce projet cher mais essentiel il y a les
questions des stocks stratégiques pardon
il faut évidemment donner un signal fort
par cette loi de programmation militaire
avec nos équipementsiers et puis il y a
toutes les questions des livraisons qui
sont d'actualité rafales scorpion
griffon Jaguar nous devons avoir par ce
débat et
par ce qui ressortira ici du Sénat sur
le ministre un message fort pour
l'industrie de guerre
un mot sur les ressources parce
qu'effectivement vous faites des
réserves une des pierres angulaires des
mobilisations possibles alors les
questions qui viendront et que nous nous
posons légitimement dans cette assemblée
sont évidemment
quel calendrier quelle formation quel
équipement
et donc nous sommes là sur ce débat
maintenant du budget monsieur le
ministre et je crois que face à ce qui
se présente nous ne pouvons pas trop
attendre et tout alors le président a
parlé de cadencement je crois que c'est
le terme exact c'est-à-dire il faut
qu'il y ait une montée sans doute plus
linéaire des questions budgétaires pour
soutenir notre armée évidemment je sais
combien le Sénat ici ados adresse à
l'ensemble des forces armées militaires
et de gendarmerie un message de soutien
en tout cas il est là aussi en tant que
question de défense nationale plus de
questions de perte de temps le temps
perdu ne se rattrape le plus et donc ce
débat est capital avec un message de
soutien à nos armées je vous remercie
merci
la discussion générale est close et nous
allons passer
texte de la commission
et bien nous commençons par l'article
premier sur lequel il n'y a pas
d'amendement et je le mets donc aux voix
qui est pour l'article premier
qui est contre
y a-t-il abstentions il est adopté nous
arrivons à l'article premier bis et nous
commençons par l'amendement